Good morning everyone, seeing that all the board members are now present, Brooks, would
you please call the roll to establish a quorum?
Good morning all.
President Darlin Hammond.
Here.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Here.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Here.
Member Olken.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
Here.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member Porter.
Here.
Member Rodriguez.
Presente.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Here.
Good morning.
Gracias todos.
All right, very good.
So we're now going to reopen item one.
So we're now going to reopen item one to take action on the preliminary report of actions
draft July 2022 meeting minutes and to have members report on their liaison assignments.
And while we're waiting for any members of the public to call in, so I think we need
to show the public comments slide if we could.
Do I have a motion from a board member to approve the July 2022 State Board of Education
draft preliminary report of action meeting minutes?
So moved.
Thank you.
Is there a second?
Second.
Okay, someone can figure out who said that first.
With that, are there any public comments?
We'll give it a little moment of wait time once you are breathing.
There are no public comments at this time.
All right.
Any further discussion?
Seeing no hands going up, Brooks, can we call the roll call vote?
Yes.
And for the record, we have Vice President Cleverwood seconding that motion.
Thank you.
President Darling-Hammond.
Aye.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Cleverwood.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Aye.
Member Olken.
Yes.
Member Roscoe-Gonzalez.
Aye.
Member Patilio-Brownson.
Yes.
Member Porter.
Abstain.
I was not present.
Member Rodriguez.
Aye.
Member Williams.
Yes.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
I was also not present.
Abstain.
Motion passes.
Thank you.
Thanks very much.
So now I want to invite the state board members to report on their liaison activities that
are not related to any items on our September agenda.
And occasionally we also have announcements that you want to bring to the board.
So I will call on the new members in case you have anything you want to add at this
moment and soon you will also be in the liaison lineup.
But let's start with member Escobedo.
Great.
I was part of the NASB meetings.
We had a couple of meetings and discussed some of the proposed increases in Title I,
which hopefully will help all of our schools in our district.
Also they have a conference coming next month.
I wasn't going to attend but I was asked to do a presentation on our work and CUS on Tier
I, Tier II.
And I will be presenting, I guess, as a board member and as a university professor as well.
And that's with NASB.
And what's really interesting in the discussion is each representative from the states a lot
of issues on staffing that's happening throughout the nation.
I find it unfortunate that many states are taking a, I think, a real short-sighted view
on facing this problem by just accepting people with bachelors to become teachers and encouraging
that without giving much focus on the necessary pedagogy and just so many complexities that
you know, to be a successful classroom teacher that is being circumvented in many of the states.
But definitely it's an issue happening throughout our nation.
I'm also liaison through West Ed and they're looking at, you know, these similar issues
and they're working on a different design, I believe, through Arizona called reimagining
the workforce, which is looking at definitely focusing on more of the mentor-teacher approach,
working with more of a group class where students get to be with social workers
throughout the day and students rotate with physical education, the arts.
So teachers may have more kids in their roster, however, they see
smaller class size throughout the day because of the rotation that they've created.
So West Ed is looking at that as a possible staffing issue, looking at just a different
design on how we educate students, I thought, that has potential, at least.
I've also been part of the regional English language specialist meeting,
a lot of discussions on our state with our EL students and a lot of issues on learning loss
and also the necessity of enhancing staff development throughout the state,
specifically with ELD designated instructions, seems like they conducted a survey and that's
the most significant gap that's happening throughout our state, which connects me with
Dr., our presenters, focus on the importance of that type of instruction just because
how that is connected to redesignation. So I believe that that was my report for the last
couple of months. Thank you so much. Vice President Glover Woods.
Thank you. I am liaison for both the advisory commission on charter schools and the California
practitioner advisory group and we have items with recommendations from both of those groups
on our agenda. So I'd just like to take this time to thank those who serve on those commissions for
their participation in last month's meetings, the discussion and recommendations are things
that definitely have helped to inform us as a board as we have moved forward on those particular
items. So thank you again to those who serve on both of those commissions.
Last week I had the opportunity to attend the 2022 annual roundup of California educational
organizations and this roundup was hosted by CASA, which is the California association of
African-American superintendents and administrators. I do want to share with you that the event was
very well attended. There were educators, parents, community members that were present.
Also included in the lineup of speakers were a couple of members of staff from the California
department of education, deputy superintendent Cheryl Cotton and also director William McGee.
Also included in the lineup of speakers was our own attorney general Rob Bonta and he spoke around
school safety. So some of the topics that were discussed kind of as a springboard for ongoing
discussion this year were transforming California schools, prioritizing students with the greatest
needs, universal pre-k, whole child wellness and again school safety. So it was a very
wonderful event. Definitely look forward to the convening next year and would invite all
of my fellow board members to participate next year if your schedule should so allow.
My last comment is just to reiterate a comment made by President Darling-Hammond during her opening
report yesterday, which is to share that the recruitment period for upcoming vacancies on
ACCS, which is the advisory commission on charter schools, CPEG, which is the California
practitioners advisory group and the instructional quality commission, also known as the IQC.
The recruitment for all three of those upcoming vacant seats has begun. So please if there's
anyone interested in being considered for a seat on one of those commissions, I invite you to visit
the website, the CDE SBE website for more details and the application. And just a reminder,
the application deadline does close on September 23rd and that concludes my report. Thank you.
Thank you so much. Member Lewis.
Yes. Good morning. I have not been part of any groups that I am the liaison to any meetings over
the last couple of months. We haven't had any, but I do look forward to the future meetings.
I kind of feel like I'm slacking here compared to the reports that came before me, but I do look
forward to when those committees and groups begin convening again and I can participate in those
meetings. But I would just like to just give a shout out to all of the students, the parents,
the staff, administrators, and hope they had a great opening to the school year and I wish
the best for all in the upcoming year. And thank you. That ends my report. We're all entitled to
a summer vacation and some of those committees needed a break. So we'll hear more in the next
round. Member McQuillin. Yes. Good morning. I'm dealing with a little bit of allergy and some of
the smoke this morning. So pardon me if I have to clear my throat. But a little bit of an update
from the committee known as the California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee.
The committee is comprised of a couple of our members from our board and a couple of members
from the California Community Colleges Chancellor's Office, also known as the CCCCO. So
when you think about this committee, think of CTE, Career Technical Education, and it's funded by
two major streams, what they call the CTIG, the California Technical Educational Incentive Grant,
which is in its seventh year of funding, and the Strong Workforce Program, SWP, that's administered
by the California Community Colleges Chancellor's Office. But the update on this is when you think
of CTE, it's not how we used to think of it, like body and vendor or mechanics or plumbers,
although that's still a part of it. But it's so much more today about health careers, technology,
business and finance, so much more of the jobs that we need for the future.
So the update I have from this committee is that we have selected some metrics that we'll be
measuring the effort in California in this area, and some of those are available now and being
captured, such as the CTE student participation rates, you know, students that take one CTE class
or two or more classes measuring that. The second metric are the graduation rates in association
with CTE participation. The third are the number of people pupils meeting academic and career
readiness standards, as defined in the college and career indicator associated with our school
dashboard. The fourth is a newer one. It's the number of pupils obtaining an industry recognized
credential, certificate, license or other measure of technical skill attainment. That's a new
metric. The fifth are the number of former pupils employed and the types of businesses in which
they are employed. And then the sixth metric are the number of former pupils enrolled in each of
the following post-secondary educational institution, a state apprenticeship program,
and a form of job training other than a state apprenticeship program. Those are new metrics,
those last three. So the update on the CTIG grant awards this past year, there was $300 million
available in the 21-22 year of the seventh year of ongoing funding. After the applications were
scored by CTE in the first round, 342 applicants were funded of about, I think there was 370
applications that came in, 342 were funded. So CTE put out a second round, a 7B round,
and 31 additional applications were funded in 7B. So a total of $248,459,000 were allocated out
this past year under CTIG. So going forward, the plan is the CCCCO, community colleges,
have contracted with Jobs for the Future, JFF, to administer and facilitate the development and
writing of the plan for California, a new CTE plan that'll pull together the CTIG and the Perkins
Five federal program. The draft plan was approved at our recent committee back on August 11th this
year. The next steps will be that CTE will post the draft plan for a 45-day public comment period,
and then CTE will present its edited draft plan along with the statements and requests from the
45-day public comment period at the November subcommittee meeting, November. The edited plan,
if approved, will then be presented at our meeting in January, as well as the board of
governors meeting in January for potential approval. So the California draft plan,
so take a look at that during the public comment period for input and edits.
And that's it on that subcommittee. One other announcement I'd like to make is that,
you know, in California we have the amber alert system, and then we have the silver alert system,
but recently the legislation approved what's called the feather alert program. As many of you know,
tribes throughout the state of California and the nation have had a rough time with missing and
murdered members as tribal members, and the 23rd of this month the governor will have an
opportunity to sign that bill, the feather alert system for California, and just so happens the
23rd is California Indian Day also. It's been around since Governor Ronald Reagan approved it,
but an opportunity to sign that bill into law for the feather alert system.
And that's all I have. Thank you.
Thank you so much. Member Olken.
Thank you. Thank you. I too have a somewhat brief report this month because I'm the liaison
to both the advisory commission on charter schools, which we have a couple of issues on
items on the agenda, and also the advisory commission on special education. So I'm going
to speak to that one. I had the pleasure of attending the August meeting of the advisory
commission on special education. It's really a joy to be a fly on the wall at this commission
meeting. The commissioners represent an incredible cross-section of stakeholders,
educators at every level, parents, policymakers, advocates. There is a clear commitment on
amongst this group to collaborate on behalf of students with disabilities,
and there's such clear respect for the varied expertise of the group. I may have said this
before, but it feels a little bit like the way the very best IEP meetings run where you have
stakeholders, all who care very much about the success of children with disabilities,
and they come together and each bring something important to the table. So I love attending these
meetings. The August meeting was the first meeting of the new school year, and so there was sort of
a start of school feel, which was fantastic. State Superintendent Thurman joined the meeting to share
some framing thoughts on the importance of the commission's work and also his hopes overall for
this new school year. And over the course of the two-day meeting, we had several new commissioners
were sworn in. There was a thorough and really helpful report from staff at the Legislative
Analyst's Office outlining the legislative and budget process. It was sort of like how a bill
becomes a law on steroids, a little schoolhouse rock moment. The commissioners reviewed last year's
accomplishments in order to begin drafting their annual report, which is actually something that's
presented to us at a future meeting, and they worked with folks from supporting inclusive practices
on a logic model to help guide their work and actions this year. And I found that really
interesting, the process of working through the logic model as they were thinking about what
their initiatives are going to be, what their legislative agenda would be, and how they can help
further the work in the field and also really provide education and support to those who are
doing the work at the school and county and district level. So it was a great meeting.
And last thing I would just say is just in terms of the new school year, it's been, I just want to
echo the congratulations and good wishes that we've heard for those in schools.
From my own experience, it's been really great to start a year that has a little bit less question
and feels more stable. And it's just been a great start. And I think both students and educators
are really ready to roll up their sleeves and get to work after a prolonged period of
strangeness. So anyway, it's great to be back in the school year, and it's great to be with
all of you. Thanks. Thank you. Member Roscoe Gonzalez.
Let me unmute myself. Well, it's been, you know, as the classroom teacher and the board,
and teaching second grade and actually have back to school night today, it's been a very,
very busy last few weeks, but really good busy work. I think that from reviewing our test scores
to getting into the trenches of what we did last year to doing that reflection process and seeing
how we can improve our instruction has been really meaningful. And it is every year as my assignment
being lays on assessment. I always say it's important for communities and families and
students, educators to be able to know how the dashboard is structured and how to access
data to help guide learning and target the needs of our students. When information is
accessible and available for educators, we can make better informed decisions for our students
and we can plan meaningful curriculum for them. In our last month's meeting, the CDE
recommended, as we mentioned, an item for using shorter adjusted blueprints for the
Smarter Balanced summative assessments. This, I think, is a huge benefit. I always think
reduced testing time allows for more instruction, just as increases that instructional time,
where I think teachers are every day developing formative and summative assessments. I know that
we're doing diagnostics. I just finished two weeks ago, assessing all my students and really
understanding deeply where their reading levels are and getting them ready for that, you know,
now getting them ready for that third grade test because we want them to be successful as they
transition to the next grade level. So I want to remind teachers that we have the tool for teachers
at our CDE website. These tools for teachers have the new formative assessment component,
the Smarter Balanced assessment system. It also has a huge collection of online resources that
are aligned with the Common Core standards that support the K-12 teachers, and I think these
formative assessments that are available have accessible strategies embedded in every instructional
resource. What I like more about these tools is that they're developed by teachers and have been
reviewed by a huge network of throughout the state of teachers. I know that at one point I was a
reviewer for some of these items, and I know that they go through a huge process of just vetting
making sure that they're aligned to grade level standards. So that concludes my presentation,
and I welcome all teachers to visit that. It's the beginning of the school year, and when you have a
little gap of time, which is limited, I know it's not always, please visit those tools for teachers,
and I think that you'll find that they're really great resources for your classroom.
Terrific. We're going to go to Member Patil Branson.
Good morning. I have two items I'm going to report on. One is that we had the successful
completion of the California State Summer School for the Arts session, which actually began in July
and included on August. For folks who might not know, the California Summer School for the Arts
is a four-week program in residence at CalArts with a host of visiting artists, special screenings,
weekly showcases of student work, and it's really designed to bring together some of the more
promising and dedicated young arts students from across the state in one very intensive program
focuses on dance, film, music, theater, visual arts, writing, and has a growing animation program.
As that concluded, the Board of Trustees, to which I'm a liaison, also held its summer strategic
planning session, so immediately hardly taking a breath for having provided a jam-packed four
weeks of content for the summer school program, the Board immediately launched into a discussion
around what is the future of the summer school, what are the assets to leverage, how to actually
connect with the many now well-established and in some circles quite famous and in pop culture
circles quite well-known alumni of the program to make sure that it's something that's widely
understood as a offering that's available to young artists throughout California.
I think there has also been an ongoing discussion around how to ensure appropriate outreach,
to ensure that the program draws across geographies, socioeconomics, language,
ethnic backgrounds, in order to really represent all of California's diversity.
In the last budget, there was an inclusion of increased funding for the summer school
for the arts, which I think was very much well received with great gratitude by both the program
and ministry, as well as the students, because much of that funding is going to go into scholarships
so that this great California offering isn't one that precludes anyone as a reason of not being
able to pay tuition for the summer, so really excited for the progress that's being made there
and more to come. Once we have actual applications becoming available, I'll be sure to flag that
in case any of you all want to share that with your networks as well. The second meeting liaison
is with the Early Childhood Policy Council, which met on July 19th, and there are really three things
I wanted to highlight there. One, and I think the one that is most obvious and closest in connection
to our work here at the state board, was an ongoing implementation of Universal TK as part
of School to Three initiatives. I think most of you all know we are rolling this out in successive
years until 2026. Also, I think there was a really robust discussion around the developmental
sort of practices within that, and I think obviously this last year's budget of bringing
down the adult-child ratio to reflect how unique the early years are and the need for different
sort of staffing ratio. I don't know if anyone's ever been in a classroom where there's 34-year-olds
and one adult, but that is not ideal for a variety of reasons, and we're really excited
that the state budget included funding to actually bring that adult-child ratio into a proportion
that better suits child development, learning, and also a better experience for everyone.
The second thing that they provided an update on was the transition of child care programs
and also early learning programs for Zero to Three to the Department of Social Services.
The Department of Social Services child care programs both overseas Zero to Three as well
as school-age after-school care, so they are critical partners in terms of ensuring that the
community wraparound supports for children, particularly from Zero to Twelve, are there to
ensure that kids have a safe place to be after school, have a place to learn, to do homework,
to be nurtured and cared for, and the exciting thing that is also on the horizon is that the
DSS rate-setting workgroup has been meeting and is very close to finalizing recommendations
around wage sufficiency and how to address teacher shortages in the earliest years.
The last thing I'll mention is that there was also a presentation on family-centered
two-generation approaches, particularly focusing on home visitation. In the context of the Early
Childhood Policy Council, oftentimes home visiting is described as a Zero to Five innovation, but I
lift it up because many school districts across California have had a history of doing home
visiting with school-age children as well, and the research on the importance of creating,
fostering, nurturing, developing, and maintaining those school-to-family connections I think is
only growing, and just wanting to cross-pollinate between the Zero to Five space and the K to Twelve
space that there are new pathways for both how to fund and cover the costs of these, some with
Medicaid, which is a new funding stream to draw down to think about how, again, to wrap around
the full supports for kids to make sure they're ready to learn, and that concludes my report.
Terrific. There's so much being done right now. Student Member Porter, would you like to make
any comments? Yes, thank you. So as you all know, this was my first month officially in office,
and with that I had two main goals. So first, I wanted to increase the visibility of the student
member position using student-friendly language on social media, and second, I wanted to increase
the number of student applicants to serve on the state board next year and the Instructional Quality
Commission student seat. So I used three main strategies to accomplish this. So first, I created
a video describing each of these positions and posted it on TikTok, YouTube, Twitter, and Instagram,
and using social media tracking insights, I am very happy to report that over 9,000 users have
seen this video, and 6,900 of those views came from Instagram, and the numbers just continue to
climb. Second, in collaboration with Los Angeles Unified School District Student Empowerment
Commission, I met with 50 students to host a town hall answering questions about these two
opportunities and encouraging younger students to begin thinking about ways to get involved
in their own schools. During the summer, I spoke at Ed100 Student Academy, speaking to over 250
young leaders throughout our state about these two opportunities as well. Lastly, I collaborated
with Generation Up and the California Association of Student Councils to co-create a social media
post explaining these positions to their audience of young leaders using student-friendly language
and graphics. So now I'm working closely with the leadership team at CASC to prepare for the Student
Advisory Board on Education's conference in October and November, so that way our students can be
represented at our November meeting and brainstorm and craft their recommendations to be presented
to this board. And that concludes my report. Thank you. Terrific. That's the first state
board member report that I've heard about a board member posting on TikTok, so I don't appreciate
the fact that you're reaching the audience in a new way. Meet them where they're at, right?
Right. Member Rodriguez. Thank you. Good morning, everyone. And yes, TikTok is the way to go.
So I will report on CTC. Member McQuillan reported on our QAP Jack, which I learned was the acronym
for the Workforce Preparation Group. And so I'll devote my time to CTC, which is actually a pretty
long report. First of all, I am so pleased to share the wonderful news that the National Board
for Professional Teaching Standards Board of Directors voted to present the James A. Kelly Award
for accomplished teaching to Dr. Mary Vixi Sandy, who is the executive director of the CTC.
A little bit about the award. It was established in honor of James Kelly, the founding president
of NBPTS. And it is given to recognize and honor individuals who provide clear,
consistent, and convincing evidence of their ability to foster Mr. Kelly's legacy of
accomplished teaching, which includes a deep-seated belief in the inherent right of all children to
a quality education, life dedicated to improving education for teachers and students, passionate
commitment to improving teaching and learning in America, unwavering dedication to the professional
integrity and competence of teachers, vision, capacity to inspire collaboration. And
among us, we have a recipient of this award, President Linda Darling-Hammond,
and others who have been awarded from California, Dr. Mike Hurst, and among other recipients or
governors and former presidents. So it is very exciting and very deserving. Dr. Sandy does
a tremendous work bringing together community partners and her vision for
our children in California and for the teaching profession is evident in every word that she
speaks. So please join me in congratulating her. Also tomorrow, I will be speaking at the Meredith
Fellows implementation conference on performance assessment. I think I was asked because I said
I wanted to make a t-shirt that says all life is a performance assessment because
you know, it's what we do, it's how we demonstrate what we know, right, and bring
information that we learn in teacher preparation school, bring it together in front of our students,
and have our students also demonstrate what they know to us with their performance tasks. So I'm
excited to represent teachers in this capacity as a national board certified teacher. I know that
teaching and learning can be messy, right? It's definitely not a filtered picture. And so I hope
to share some of how a reflective practitioner serves our students in a way that
we set valuable goals for them and take them through that helix to make sure that they
meet those goals and we guide them along the way. So I've said this before, I wouldn't want
an airplane pilot to not demonstrate what they know before they get behind an airplane that I'll
be flying in, or a surgeon not being able to demonstrate to other professionals that they
know what they're doing, just like I wouldn't want a teacher in front of my students who hasn't
demonstrated to a body that has set the standards for teaching that they know what they're doing.
So I'm very excited about presenting tomorrow at the conference.
So some of the updates of the CTC meeting that happened in August, the commission's literacy
work group undertook a review of the commission's adopted educator preparation program standards
related to the literacy teacher performance expectations and submitted recommendations for
consideration by the CTC in accordance with SB 48. SB 48 was talked about in the June meeting,
but hopefully I'll give you enough information with this report if you're not familiar with the
Senate bill. So the initial focus of the work group has been giving the updates on
the program standards. The literacy work group will have a final meeting because there are
deadlines to SB 488 on September 13th to review the data from the field and surveys as well as
feedback and direction from commissioners before recommending any final revisions that they think
are necessary and appropriate. And staff will present the full set of the literacy program
standards and teacher performance expectations to the commission for adoption in October
2020 or coming up next month. The product that will result from the requirements of SB 48 is to
develop universal program standards and teacher performance expectations, TPEs, that will not only
provide high standards and programs for traditional K-12 community, but to also meet the very unique
developmental learning needs of PK3 students and all students with dyslexia. Establishing
standards for PK3 and dyslexia needs that are a cookie cutter of grade one will not work.
Literacy standards need to reflect the reality of the developmental stages of all early learners.
For the CAL APA, which is the Administrator Performance Assessment, so we're moving on here,
the CTC heard an update on the first four years of implementation, and it's very favorable. People
are showing that they're very pleased with the process, and they were informed about
leadership cycle one, which is analyzing data to inform school improvement and promote equity.
Cycle two, facilitating communities of practice, and cycle three, supporting teacher growth.
So in June, a couple of meetings ago, the commission endorsed the proposed authorization statement
and credential requirements for the early childhood education specialist.
The CTC reviewed and adopted the proposed regulations
for newly repurposed PK3 EC specialist instruction credential, and so that's very,
very exciting. The requirements for PK3 include possession of a bachelor's or higher degree
from a regionally accredited institution, completion of a professional preparation program
that meets PK EC program standards, passage of a commission approved teaching performance
assessment, and passage of either the RECA or a commission approved literacy performance assessment.
I'm going to go to some very exciting news that makes me tremendously grateful
to live in California as an educator. And that is the enacted 2022-23 budget
as it relates to the commission. The budget provides $330.5 million for a total of 29 new positions
for the agency and fee waivers. $24 million one-time general fund
to waive feature examination and assessment fees. And these examinations include the CBEST,
CSET, RECA, TPA, and TPA and APA. So now I won't go into detail if you want the details
on the specific positions that will be opening at the CTC. I'm happy to email those to you,
but they are long. But in there, they include reading and literacy grants,
accreditation, Center for Teaching Careers, $1.7 million, a one-time general fund to support
Tulare County Office of Education to continue administering the California Center on Teaching
Careers. So that concludes my report.
You've gotten off. Thank you so much. Member Yoshimoto-Tari, would you like to make some
remarks? Hi. Good morning. I just wanted to offer my personal reflections. This being
my first state board meeting. And yesterday's experience has reaffirmed for me the impact of
the decisions that the State Board of Education makes, particularly given the diverse student
population that we serve, but also the diversity of county offices, districts, schools, and
communities that we serve. So it kind of had three reflections at this point, which one was
the importance of the systems of gathering meaningful feedback and engagement. So I'm
happy to hear all of my colleagues liaison reports and relationships because that's so important.
Secondly, that I really highlight the state's efforts to do the outreach that we talked about
yesterday, the communication, the webinars, the different toolkits, such as the one that was
released last month. And then finally, third is just what board member Porter reinforced this
morning, which is that young people are a source of inspiration and opportunity for us to continue
to learn and innovate. So as many of my colleagues have shared, just let's make this a wonderful
school year. Campus and school is often a place where students experience joy, wellness, in
addition to the teaching and learning that happens, and a place where real innovation can happen. So
thank you again. Terrific. Thank you. And I'll just say briefly, so much of the work that we've
all been doing has had to do with implementation of all of these major initiatives over the last
couple of years. And member Petillo Bronson brought us up to date on the UPK, the universal
TK and other early childhood work. There is a lot of work going on in the teacher pathways. And
so I've intersected with some of that around the launch of program design conversations at
the California State University system. I addressed one group of their early childhood
providers. And across the state, we're trying to really get people to think about the challenges
of the new ECE credential and the many, many ways that we will build that educated workforce. And
a lot is happening to be pleased about, and a lot of it happening with great alacrity and speed.
Member Escobedo talked about the fact that there's a lot of staffing challenge around the country.
Of course, we put in place multi-billions of dollars for residencies and Golden State
scholarships and career pathways for paraprofessionals and many other ways to
address our shortages. We are beginning to see some changes. We've got an uptick in enrollments
in teacher education that is noticeable. And there are, from a recent analysis of the CTC
surveys, about 1,400 people who were involved in residencies last year, candidates who came
through residency programs. They were the most positive about their preparation experiences
of the various categories of entrance into the profession. 70 plus residencies now exist across
the state. And that is beginning to spread across the country. Texas has just put about a billion
dollars into residencies in that state as well. So we are seeing that grow. And there's a lot of,
with all these programs, there's a lot of growing pains and implementation concerns.
And we're trying to stay on top of that particular props to our state board staff member,
Rigel Massara, who keeps track of all of that and is really enabling a lot of smoothing of the way
for many of these programs. We've also just gotten going on centers that were funded in the prior
budget for accelerated learning, for helping support professional development, for people
who may be involved in classroom teaching and tutoring and small group instruction
to support really enabling students to move more rapidly in their skill development.
Some would say to catch up from the learning lag that has experienced. So we now have
several centers across the state that are now beginning to do that work.
The new IEP template and other innovations that were part of the budget previously is
continuing to be developed. There's a team that is working on that for our special education students
and also on the development of a pathway to a diploma for students who previously were not
able to do that. So that's very exciting progress in that arena. You all know about the fact that
the community schools initiatives are continuing to roll out and there will be several opportunities
to hear about the gains and the strategies that different districts are taking. And the
Department of Education is about to do a set of webinars that will bring people in and let them
learn from each other. So you may want to keep an eye out for that if that's an area that you're
working with. And finally the school year is starting as many people have said with a sense of
normalcy and a sense of going direct and being able to be back fully. At the same time we do
continue to have concerns about the variants of COVID-19 and about the virus. So
this afternoon I'll partner with our friends at the California Department of Public Health
in a sort of public service hour about what districts can expect and ways in which they can
keep students safe, engage in mitigation strategies. We'll hear from several districts
that are doing very thoughtful work on everything from vaccinations to testing to
their whole range of mitigation strategies that we want to keep people alert to so that we can
in fact stay in business, keep kids in school and be healthy this year. So with that I will move us
to our agenda for the day and we are going to take up the waiver consent calendar.
And we're going to take up waiver consent items 1 through 9, W1 through W9. We're going to open
the phone line for public comments so let's get the public comment slide up there.
We're going to take a moment to allow people to queue up and call in if they care to do so
this is our moment for mindfulness. Take a breath.
While everyone's taking their mindfulness break we would just like to remind the public that this
is public comment for the waivers as President Darlene Hammond just remind everyone for waivers
W1 through W9. If you're seeking to call in on the subsequent item, item 11 regarding
the charter appeal please call back at that time. We see that there are a number of callers that
based on the area code we think may be calling in for that item. We would just like to remind
them that this is not the moment for that. Thank you that's very helpful. So if you are
calling for the next item on the charter appeal hang up now and call back.
And with that let me ask is there any is there any public comment on the waiver items?
Is anybody still on the phone? We see some callers dropping but it appears we may have two.
Okay. Okay I will open the phone line now. Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello. Okay it looks like they hung up. We have one caller left. I will answer that one and we'll
see if it's for this item. Caller please state your name and affiliation for the record. You
have one minute. Your time starts now. Caller ending in the last four digits two zero two two
you are live. Please start your public comment now. Okay it looks like that they were all for
the next item. That concludes public comment for the waiver consent items. All right given that
there's no other public comment I'll now ask for a motion on waivers W-1 through W-9. Do I have a
motion? So moved. Thank you. Do I have a second? Second. Thank you. We'll now hold a roll call
vote. Brooks can you call the roll? President Harlan Hammond. Aye. Member Escobedo. Aye. Vice
President Glover-Woods. Yes. Member Lewis. Yes. Member McQuillan. Aye. Member Olken.
Yes. Member Orozco-Gonzalez. Yes. Member Petillo-Brownson. Yes. Member Porter. Yes.
Member Rodriguez. Yes. Member Yoshimoto-Towry. Yes. Motion passes unanimously.
All right we're moving on to item number 11 which is the appeal of the denial of a petition for
the establishment of a classroom-based charter pursuant to California Education Code section
47605K2. It's consideration of evidence to hear or summarily deny the appeal of
Mayacamas Charter Middle School which was denied by the Napa Valley Unified School District and
the Napa County Board of Education. The California Department of Education recommends that we hear
the appeal and this item will be presented by Stephanie Farland of the CDE. Stephanie. Good
morning. Good morning President Darling-Hammond, board members, deputy superintendent Sarah Neville
Morgan. It's good to be here today. Before I begin I just want to recognize that today kicks
off National Hispanic Heritage Month and as the daughter of Mexican immigrants I just want to
recognize the contributions of all of Latino and Hispanic and Latinx Americans in this country and
specifically those of my parents who I'm very proud of and have contributed much to California
and to this country so I just wanted to recognize that it does start today.
This morning as President Darling-Hammond mentioned this item will be to decide to hear or
to make a decision to hear or summarily deny the appeal of Mayacamas Charter Middle School.
A little background the Mayacamas Charter Middle School petition proposes a new grade six through
eight charter school. MCMS as we will call it submitted its petition to the Napa Valley Unified
School District pursuant to California and code section 47605A. The district denied the petition
on December 9th, 2021 by a vote of seven to zero. MCMS then appealed the petition to the
the MVUSD's denial to the Napa County Board of Education pursuant to code section 47605K1AI.
The county denied the petition on March 15th, 2022 by a vote of five to two.
MCMS then submitted its petition to the California State Board of Education on April 14th,
2022 pursuant to Ed code section 47605K2.
In this item pursuant to Ed code section 47605K2E the SBA shall decide to either hear the appeal or
summarily deny a review of the appeal based on the documentary record. If the SBE decides to
hear the appeal the matter will be considered in the following item. If the SBE decides to
summarily deny the appeal the decisions of the District and County Board of Education will stand
and there will be no further determination or sorry no further hearings on this item.
Our recommendation the CDE's recommendation today is that the State Board of Ed vote to hear the
Maya Commons Charter School appeal. At its August 11th, 2022 meeting the Advisory Commission on
Charter Schools voted to adopt the CDE's recommendation that the SBE hear the MCMS appeal
and that motion passed by a vote of seven to one.
MCMS has met all appeal timelines and submitted a record of the findings from NVUSD and NCBOE
and a written submission with citations to the documentary record pursuant to Ed code section
47605K2A. MCMS appeals both the District and the County's decisions to deny its petition.
NVUSD and NCBOE also provided written oppositions with specific citations to the documentary record
pursuant to Ed code section 47605K2C. These documents demonstrate that there is a factual
dispute concerning the procedural history of NCBOE's denial of MCMS's petition.
Based on the CDE's review of all documents and in alignment with the ACCS's recommendation the
CDE recommends that the SBE hear the MCMS appeal and that concludes our presentation.
At this point we will now open the phone line for public comments so we want to put the public
comment slide up there again. This item is limited. Oh sorry we're beginning the public
hearing um President Darling-Hammond correct not public comment. I'm just following my script
and it says this is the public comment um oh okay sorry you're correct sorry I think the next item
will be yes I'm sorry I thank you for correcting me I in my mind thank you uh so we open the phone
line for public comment the item this item is limited to decision whether or not to hear the
appeal. People wishing to make comments on the merits of the appeal and whether there has been
an abuse of discretion should please wait and comment on the next item item 12. The members
of the public wishing to provide comment on this item may do so by calling the telephone number
and using the access code provided on the slide that is shown now. We encourage you to please state
your name and affiliation for the record. Please remember to turn down the speaker volume of your
computers if you're following the live feed and speakers will be limited to one minute each.
Speakers needing Spanish translation will be given two minutes. Are there any public comments
again just on the whether we would hear the appeal?
We do have a number of people signed up for public comment I will open up the phone line now.
Oh I also should ask the translator to provide those instructions in Spanish
for colors and I need translation when they when they give their input.
Hello good morning I am the Spanish translator that will be providing the instructions.
Okay we will start the public comment now.
Good morning caller please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute your time starts now.
Caller ending in the last four digits seven four two one please start your public comment now.
Good morning members of the state board my name is Kathy Mancini and I'm calling on behalf of
the California School Employees Association urging the board to summarily deny this appeal
just because there is a dispute of just because the petitioners disagree with the facts in this
case does not mean that an abusive discretion occurred and we would strongly encourage the
board to summarily deny thank you. Thank you next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now.
Hi thank you so much for the honor to speak to the board today I am Hannah Henry calling from
Napa California. I ask the board to deny this appeal we have spent enough time and resources
the entire district and the county have spent already enough time on this
charter petition which is essentially an effort for the privileged few and we have much work to do
and much work has been done already to address the needs of middle schoolers. I have a fifth grader
going into sixth grade and I have three older children who have all gone through Napa public
middle schools we need to focus our efforts on that process on the new schools and this school
year please deny this appeal it's a waste of our time thank you. Thank you next caller please state
your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now.
Good morning President Berlingham and Vice President Glover Woods and esteemed board members
this is Gina Plait on behalf of the California Charter Schools Association.
We are honored to be here on behalf of the students and families that are asking for this
program and we support the recommendation from the department and we encourage you to vote to
hear the appeal of myocomis charter middle school thank you. Thank you next caller please state your
name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now.
Hi my name is Alicia Cronbach I'm a parent of a middle school child I live here in Napa County
and my son was born and raised in Napa County. Students are kaleidoscope of strength and needs
in the public schools should reflect that MCMS is a viable fiscally responsible and diverse choice
for a community that has consistently lost choices in the last five years. I respectfully ask that the
SBE hear the MCM appeal and make a decision based on that thank you. Thank you next caller
please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now.
Hi my name is Marisa Pless and my daughter attends Pueblo Vista Elementary School
and we are so grateful to be part of the public school system in Napa but we ask that you deny
the myocomis charter petition the students would be negatively impacted in the current schools and
resources should stay where they're at and improve the systems that are already in place.
Thank you so much for hearing me and for your time thank you. Thank you next caller please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now.
Hi good morning thank you so much my name is Sylvia Regalado-Zaklott I am a parent of the Napa
Valley Unified School District we have three children that have gone pre-k through currently
in high school now and I want the state and the board to adamantly oppose deny hearing this any
further. You have put the due diligence on your local governments, county, school districts to
make decisions they have painfully gone through all of the appeals process with this charter and
have found that the best interest of over 16,000 students in Napa Valley benefit from having a
collective school district where many changes have been made and many students are currently
thriving and those options are still available to them and we welcome them to come into our schools
and be a part of a great community that is flourishing please deny this appeal and continue
to invest in students by not wasting tax dollars thank you. Thank you.
Hi I just wanted to jump in real quickly to remind our public callers that these calls are
really solely about the decision about whether or not to hear the appeal if you're calling in about
item 12 which will occur if the board votes to hear the appeal about whether it's to affirm or
to reverse please call in for item 12 if you're calling in to comment on whether it should be
heard or not please proceed thank you. Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time starts now.
Hi my name is Marie Dennett I speak as a community member a mother and a trauma-informed
health care provider to advocate for this appeal. NBUSD has and continues to create harm in the
community by working so persistently to block myacomis from opening a smaller unique mentally
health-focused creative and diversified learning environment myacomis desires to provide is not
only desired but desperately needed in our community. NBUSD has made it abundantly clear
community. NBUSD has made it abundantly clear that they have no interest in listening to our
community beyond the example they set by spreading vicious rumors about myacomis throughout this
process and working incessantly to stop myacomis for an opening they have also recently closed a
valued and cherished 20-year program for preschool age children with special needs and have for
financial reasons absorbed the children into their own district despite being doing any of the
ethical preparation needed to make a transition like this they didn't listen to the parents of
the children children who that program served either and the meetings I've attended NBUSD has
blatantly stated that they don't care if they didn't have the support to do it because they
have the right legally this says a lot about the way it works it is not for the benefit.
Thank you. Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute
your time starts now. My name is Wendy Beltrani retired NBUSD staff member and I'm speaking today
in support of myacomis charter in the course of the charter application process myacomis was
demonized by NBUSD characterized as something that would take resources from our spanish speaking
families in addition NAFA families were told that it was necessary to close two beloved middle schools
to avoid program cuts and financial ruin and yet now we're hearing the same dire predictions and
are being asked to support a 200 million dollar bond measure further exacerbating the lack of
trust families are feeling with the school district. Napa Valley Unified's habit of telling
Napa families what they want and need instead of asking them has set us on a path to middle school
mediocrity one size does not fit all myacomis will fill a need that is sorely lacking in our
current middle school offerings there are kids who will not thrive in the big box schools our
community needs a public charter option please consider hearing the appeal for the myacomis
charter thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time starts now our city needs a public charter option please consider
caller ending in the last four digits 3304 you are live please start your public comment now
uh hello this is Claire Crawford within the public interest and I urge the board to summarily deny
this appeal the fact of the matter is that the district and the county both appropriately
evaluated this petition as having a negative fiscal and community impact on NBUSD and nothing
in the record indicates that there was any prejudice against the petitioners
in coming to this conclusion it's very clear that this is a tough decision that the district was
required to take to ensure the fiscal stability of the entire district and both the district and
the county took appropriate steps navigating this brand new law that was intended to allow
districts to make these kinds of tough decisions without the state reversing them so I urge you to
summarily deny this petition thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record your you have one minute your time starts now
good morning my name is Dr. Veigles CSCA chapter president NAPA 184 so not only does it affect the
students but you guys got to also consider the 600 plus that are going to get affected by
approving this charter I'm in favor of denial I just want to thank everybody for participating
and I hope everybody has a great day thank you thank you next caller please state your
name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hi my name is Jackie Clayton I am the first vice president CSCA NAPA chapter 184 I am also
employed in NAPA Valley Unified I just want to go and say my my part of the investigation
the evaluation the appropriate processes will follow the NAPA Valley Unified and their conclusion
it is non-biased it is 100 accurate and I ask that denial be the decision we care about our
students and these are our students we want you to deny the charter thank you thank you
next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts
now my name is Kim Smith and I'm a parent in Napa Valley Unified I have two kids who've
been through the system and are in it now I'd like the state to agree to review this appeal
because the way the district has tried to balance their own internal financial needs versus truly
assessing what is best for the community has been mishandled very badly and I think the state needs
to weigh in and recognize fiscal management does matter but community engagement community
involvement what communities want matters as well and when a group of parents decides they
need something very different from what the district is capable of offering like Maya Camas
and a small system we need to give them a chance it took the district 15 years to learn from the
river system river charter school and they are not adopting any of the practices Maya Camas is
asking us to consider asking you to consider so I'd like you to approve this because the
district made a mistake in assessing community impact as only considering their own employment
roles and not the wide effect on the rest of the district and parents and students
thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one
minute your time starts now
caller ending in the last four digits eight four nine six you are live please start your public
comment now I'm calling in support of Maya Camas middle school as we all know middle school can be
a challenging time creating meaningful options is key to successful transition for many kids
NVUSD had this unique option one that the community embraced and students thrived in the
abrupt removal of this program the highest performing middle school in our district was
strangely justified by NVUSD they are telling us the things that we need rather than listening
to what students need and dividing the community in the process this is why people are leaving
the school district the data does not support this change and Maya Camas is the unique solution
that will allow students to grow and thrive in a challenging and supportive environment
please consider reversing the school district's choice and support Maya Camas charter school
thank you so much for all of your work thank you thank you next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hello my name is Maria Beltran I am a parent of the NVUSD school district I want to ask that you
appeal the for the Maya Camas we have schools have closed in the district because of the enrollment
closing the district because of the enrollment being low and opening up a new school just does
not seem feasible at this time with schools being closed and middle schools being merged together
so I please let you deny this appeal thank you thank you next caller please state your
name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hi my name is Linda Inlay I was the former head of school of River School there is a desperate need
for student well-being today the large middle schools in Napa do not fulfill the needs of all
students the introverts the kids who don't quite fit in who are extremely sensitive or experience
trauma they're good SEL programs who work in some schools and not in a lot of others the
difference is the health of the culture as Peter Drucker said culture needs strategies for breakfast
Maya Camas unique response to thriving is a 50-year-old school culture approach where the
hidden curriculum of culture fulfills students need for belonging for economy for caring adults
model the qualities desired in students an authentic way of being versus a curriculum you
teach now more than ever all students need this type of program not being offered at other Napa
schools please allow this appeal to be heard thank you next caller please state your name
and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good morning it's Eric Premack with the charter schools development center
I believe the track record here clearly grant clearly justifies the granting of the hearing
here and we support the staff recommendation to hear it thank you thank you next caller
please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
caller ending in the last four digits three three six three you're live please start your public
comment now thank you okay thank you I'm a mother of two middle schoolers in Napa Valley
Unified School District and I'm calling in support of the charter appeal for my comments
because despite public data regarding student population projections through the next 20
years showing the lowest rates of variability or loss of students at the middle school level in Napa
the district has closed two sorely needed middle schools under very duplicitous means and motives
and leaving us with only two horribly overcrowded low scoring middle schools where fights are normal
every day and or we have one ESL dual language academy which actually does not meet the needs
of the entire student community it's also recently removed an entire half an hour of
learning instruction per day and shortened student lunch times to only 15 minutes our
district does not foster a positive environment for the intellectual advancement of our collective
student population and it only hinders it and will continue to and for the record my
comments is not a private school funded with public school dollars it's actually a public school
with higher academic standards thank you all of Napa students thank you next caller please
state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good morning my name is grace and I'm a recent alumni of NBUSD school district I fully support
the board's hearing of my economist charter middle school appeal investing in a variety
of choices for students as well as providing social emotional learning opportunities is
essential to many student successes and ability to thrive within public education my successes
as an NBUSD alumni and now college alumni can be largely attributed to the experiences I had within
river middle school as a public charter option within the time I think the current state of
our community and larger society has attested that giving people choice and autonomy within
their decisions is essential I urge the board to put children and their educational experiences
at the center of this choice thank you so much for your time thank you that concludes public
comment for item number 11 thank you thank you very much I appreciate all the public callers will
first ask our liaisons Vice President Glover Woods and member Olken if they have any
initial comments before we get into our discussion Vice President Glover Woods
I think actually I'm going to lead us off on this one oh okay if you have an arrangement go for it
yeah thank you um I um both member Glover Woods and I attended the ACCS meeting where this item
was brought um and um it was clear from the testimony that there is a dispute um as has
been recommended that should be considered by the state board as been recommended by both CDC CDE
and the ACCS um and I want to remind us um that as we have heard on this item we're only deciding
whether there is sufficient evidence for us to hear the appeal um we are not making any
that that's the only role that we have at this point thank you
Vice President Glover Woods did you want to add anything yes uh President Darlingham and I I
definitely would and my addition is really more of a reiteration that uh what we are deciding at this
time is to decide to either hear the charter denial appeal or summarily deny the appeal
because we don't feel there are any grounds to actually hear the appeal and I do want to share
with my fellow board members that based on the information that we've received in the documentary
record and the discussion of this appeal that member Olken and I had opportunity to hear at
the August ACCS meeting um I do believe that there is sufficient evidence for us to hear
the appeal and I would recommend that we do so thank you all right well now let's launch
board discussion and uh see what questions or comments other board members have
give a moment
if there are no comments or questions otherwise we can take a motion
I move that we hear the appeal that is before us here on item 11
which is the charter petition from Maya Commis Charter Middle School
and do I have a second I second that all right Brooks can you call the roll for a vote
President Darlingham and aye member Escobedo aye Vice President Glover Woods yes member Lewis
yes member McQuillan yes member Olken yes member Orozco-Gonzalez yes member Petillo-Brownson
yes member Porter yes member Rodriguez yes member Yoshimoto-Towry yes motion passes
passes all right before we want into item 12 which is the public hearing then concerning the
appeal I'd love to give us a break because it's going to be a long next session we just had our
coffee so we'll take 15 minutes now and come back at 10 10 and we'll be ready for our to dive into
the hearing see you then just turn off your video I mute but stay connected
all right uh welcome back uh item 12 is a public hearing regarding the appeal of the denial of a
petition for the establishment of a classroom-based charter school pursuant to California I apologize
President Darlingham I just need to re-establish a quorum oh I'm sorry please re-establish the
quorum uh President Darlingham here member Escobedo here member Glover Woods here
President Glover Woods apologies I'm going too fast uh member Lewis here member McQuillan here
member Olken here member Orozco-Gonzalez
here member Petillo-Brownson here here member Rodriguez presented member Yoshimoto-Towry
hearing thank you we have a quorum all right so item 12 is a public hearing regarding the
appeal of the denial of a petition for the establishment of a classroom-based charter
school pursuant to California education code section 47605 k2 consideration of the allegations
of abuse of discretion made by maya commis charter middle school which was denied by the nappa valley
unified school district and the nappa county board of education and this item the california
department of education recommends that we affirm the decisions to deny the petition
the item will be presented by Stephanie Farland of the CDE and Stephanie you may begin great thank
you um in the previous item the state board of ed decided to hear the appeal based on the documentary
record so this is what we'll be doing today um item number 12 some background in this item the
california state board of education will hear the maya commis charter middle school appeal
pursuant to california education code 47605 k2e the sbe may affirm the determination of the
governing board of the school district or the county board of education or both of those
determinations or the sbe may reverse only upon a determination that there was an abuse of discretion
if the sbe does not take action to affirm or reverse the determinations of the governing
board of the school district and the county board of education to deny the mcms petition would stand
the california department of education recommends that the sbe
affirm the nappa valley unified school districts and the nappa county board of education's decisions
to deny the petition to establish mcms pursuant to ed code section 47605 k2e
this recommendation is based on the cde's review of the following mcms's written submission which
fails to show an abuse of discretion by either nbusd or ncboe the documentary record and written
oppositions by the district and county
abuse of discretion um we we did go over this at the july meeting but but i know we have a new
member today and so a couple new members um so to uh review abuse of discretion is the most
deferential standard of review the sbe is required to give deference to the decision of the school
district governing board and county board of education to deny the petition the sbe's review
is limited to limited to a determination of whether the district governing board
or county board's decision to deny the charter petition was arbitrary capricious
and tarot entirely lacking in evidentiary support unlawful or procedurally unfair
so now we'll go over the maya commas charter middle school's allegations of abuse of discretion
mcms stated the following allegations of abuse of discretion by the nbusd and these will be the
allegations against the district the factual findings adopted by the district board on
december 9th 2021 are not supported by substantial evidence in the record the district board failed
to proceed in the manner required by law because the district did not provide a fair and impartial
petitioning process information regarding mcms's claims can be found in item attachment one
mcms's allegations against the county mcms stated the following allegations of abuse of discretion
by the ncboe the county board's march 15th 2022 decision to deny the mcms petition is not supported
by the purported factual findings in the county's post-denial declaration findings ratified on april
5th 2022 the county board's post-denial factual findings are not supported by evidence in the
the county board's post-denial factual findings are not supported by evidence in the documentary
record the county board failed to proceed in the manner required by law when it failed to
either grant the charter petition or timely adopt specific written factual findings to deny
so those were the petitioners allegations and now we'll go over the districts and
counties written opposition to their appeal
and the usd argues it did not abuse its discretion that its review process was fair and compliant
and compliant with education code and that its findings in support of denial were supported by
evidence in the record and the usd denied the mcms charter petition based on the following
findings the petition presents an unsound educational program the petitioners are
demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the program set forth in the petition and the
implement the program set forth in the petition the petition does not contain reasonably
comprehensive descriptions of elements a through o of ed code section 47605 c5
the proposed charter is demonstrably unlikely to serve the interests of the entire community
in which the school is proposing to locate the county written opposition to mcms's appeal
ncbo e argues it did not abuse its discretion because the county board complied with all
procedural obligations in the law regarding the mcms petition the county board properly
adopted specific written factual findings in its support of its decision to deny the petition
the county board's factual findings are supported by substantial evidence in the documentary record
ncboe denied the mcms charter petition based on the following finding mcms is demonstrably
unlikely to serve the interests of the entire community in which the school is proposing to
locate the california department of education's review of mcms's appeal
based on the cde's review of mcms's written submission documentary record and the written
oppositions from the district and county the cde has determined that nbusd and ncboe did not
abuse their discretion in their denials of the mcms petition a summary of the nbusd's and
ncboe's findings regarding the mcms petition mcms's allegations of abusive discretion and
the district and county's oppositions is provided an attachment one
section 47605 k2a states the petitioner shall include the findings and documentary record from
the governing board of the school district and the county board of education and a written
submission detailing with specific citations to the documentary record how the governing board
of the school district or the county board of education or both abuse their discretion mcms
based on the cde's review of the written submission and documentary record mcms has
not met its burden of detailing with specific citations to the documentary record how the
district or county abused their discretion in the denial of the charter petition
as will be shown in the upcoming slides mcms's written submission lacks detail and does not
contain specific citations to the documentary record that support its appeal as required by
statute although the petitioners did provide 63 references to the documentary record the references
do not establish the evidentiary support necessary to show how the district and county abuse their
discretion and their decisions to deny the charter petition cde's review of mcms's claims related to
the district's findings mcms states the factual findings adopted by the district board on december
9th 2021 are not supported by substantial evidence in the record it is important to note that
substantial evidence that term is not the legal standard to be applied in this instance is not
required by education code and the usd's denial was based on four findings under edco's section
47605c but mcms's written submission includes only limited detail relating relating to a portion
of one finding and does not specifically address each finding the sbe must determine whether the
district's determination as a whole constitutes an abuse of discretion the petitioners did not
address how the determination to deny was an abuse of discretion
when addressing the district's findings the written submission contains seven end notes with
citations to the documentary record however mcms has not detailed how any of these citations
challenge the evidentiary basis of nbusd's findings rather mcms's written submission details
mcms's disagreement with nbusd's conclusions arguing that nbusd should have reached different
conclusions but mcms does not explain how any of the citations supports claim that nbusd abuses
discretion and denying the mcms petition mcms's written submission effectively asks the state
board to come to substitute its own judgment for the districts which is not permitted under the
abuse of discretion standard the next slide will give an example with a screenshot we thought that
might be helpful when cde staff reviewed the written submission
i did mention that they had many end notes so if you look here end note number 57 cites two pages
for example the district staff's report criticism of the mcms's budget is almost entirely
predicated on the incorrect assumption that the school cannot meet its year one enrollment target
they have an end note there so we follow the end note to see what the specific allegation of
abuse of discretion is and note 57 cites two pages of findings which lists several specific
facts as the evidentiary basis for the district's conclusion that the mcms fiscal plan is unrealistic
that's what was at the end of that particular citation citation number 58 cites two pages of
mcms's response to the district's findings wherein mcms argues for different conclusions
but does not challenge the evidentiary basis of the nbusd's findings and the reason we are
showing an example is just to sort of in a uh to show what it was that we followed the the
the department of ed as you know and we've said this before that we're not authorized by statute
to consider the quality of the charter the need for the charter the value of the charter or the
support for the charter our review is restricted to the review of the documentary record and when
there is sufficient evidence to support local decisions and so the burden is on the charter
to specifically cite how the district and or county boards abuse their discretion and in the
case of the citations that we received from the petitioners we did not find that next slide
mcms's written submission then states that mcms has previously refuted all the district's findings
and then cites its entire 28 page response to the end response to the district staff report
however the written submission fails to include specific citations within ms mcms's response to
the staff report to support their appeal and fails to explain how its response to the district
staff report supports its claim that the district abused its discretion and denying the mcms petition
claims related to the district's findings conclusion mcms's written submission contains only
limited citations and it's challenged to the district's findings lacks the necessary detail
to support mcms's allegation that the district abused its discretion with regard to its findings
in support of denial therefore there is insufficient evidence for the sbe to find an abuse of discretion
related to the district's findings in support of denying mcms's petition
we'll now move on to the petitioner's claims related to the county's findings
mcms states the county board's march 15 2022 decision to deny the mcms petition is not supported
by the purported factual findings in the county's post-denial declaration findings ratified on
april 5 2022 mcms bases the above allegation on its claim that the county's findings simply
parroted back the language of ed code section 47605 c7 without providing any supporting facts or legal
without providing any supporting facts or legal conclusions however ncboe's findings clearly list
several specific facts in support of its denial of the mcms petition which have been included in
attachment one the second claim related to the county's findings mcms states the county board's
findings are not supported by evidence in the documentary record as it did with its challenge
the district's findings mcms's written submission here contains some citations to the documentary
record but does not challenge the evidentiary basis for the county's findings rather mcms's
written submission argues for its own analysis and conclusions failing to explain how the county
abuses discretion in denying the mcms petition here again mcms's written submission is effectively
asking the sb to substitute its own judgment for the counties which is not permitted under the
abuse of discretion standard therefore there is insufficient evidence for the sb to find an
abuse of discretion related to ncboe's findings cd's review of procedural allegations against the
district this is a recap of what the cd received as part of the documentary record mcms's claims
that the district failed to proceed in the manner required by law because the district did not
provide a fair and impartial petitioning process specifically mcms asserts petitioners were permitted
to communicate only with the district's legal counsel the district demanded petitioners attend
a capacity interview which focused on the two parent lead petitioners lack of experience to
themselves for them this is a direct quote so i'll rephrase a little bit petitioners lack of
experience um to operate and run the school which is not what is proposed in the petition
the meeting never happened which a district cited as support for denial the district staff
report is self-serving and one-sided there was no discussion amongst the district board members at
the meeting on december 9 2021 where the mcms petition was denied and the video feed of the
virtual meeting went blank for nearly 10 minutes during a break in the middle of the board's
deliberations the superintendent and each district board member prejudged the facts before the
december 9th meeting and came prepared with written statements in opposition to the mcms petition
each of the statements listed on the previous slide includes a citation to the documentary
record however the evidence referenced in the citation does not demonstrate how nbusd's
process for reviewing mcms's petition was unfair two of the citations refer to documents that
mcms itself prepared which makes similar allegations but do not specify how or why the
act complained of is procedurally unfair an additional citation references a public comment
made by a parent in the district but does not say why the comment is evidence that the nbusd's
actions were procedurally unfair in another instance the citations refer to 28 pages of
the transcript from the nbusd's board's december 9th 22 meeting 2022 meeting this citation
undermines mcms's claim that there was no discussion among board members at that meeting
and is not a specific citation also mcms's claims about the district's capacity interview are not
supported by evidence on november 3rd 2021 nbusd emailed mcms explaining that they would not exclude
other individuals from attending the meeting and that the purpose of the capacity interview for
was for the charter school's leadership team to demonstrate knowledge of the petition
and capacity to successfully implement it and that therefore the district's questions
would be directed to the petitioners and just as a side note capacity interviews are not a
requirement of the petitioning process some authorizers do it just to get to know the
petitioners better and and understand their capacity but it is not a requirement of the
petitioning process that's an end code additionally the fact that the board members have prepared
statements which they read into the record does not demonstrate that the district did not consider
the petition the staff recommendations or the mcms's responses to the staff recommendations
cde's review of procedural allegations against the county mcms's claims that the county board
failed to proceed in the manner required by law when it failed to either grant the charter
petition or timely adopt specific written factual findings to deny pursuant to ed code section 47605
the governing of the governing board of the school district and or county board of education
shall either grant or deny the charter within 90 days of the receipt of the petition
mcms asserts that its submission of its petition to the county on december 21 2022
required ncboe to grant mcms's petition or adopt written findings to deny by march 21 2022
the documentary record shows and all parties agree that ncboe voted to deny mcms's petition
on march 15 2022 and adopted written factual findings on april 5 2022
and that all can be found in the documentary record and the citation cited there
both both ncboe and nvusd state that while mcms mcms initially submitted its petition
to the county on december 21 2022 mcms failed at that time to fulfill the requirements of ed
code section 47605 k1a which states the following at the same time the petition is submitted to the
county board of education the petitioner shall also provide a copy of the petition to the school
district the district and county provided evidence along with their written oppositions
which established that mcms did not submit submit its appeal to both nvusd and ncboe pursuant to ed
code section 47605 k1 ai until january 5 2022 as the mcms petition was not properly submitted
in accordance with statute until january 5 2022 ncboe's 90-day statutory timeline pursuant to ed
code 47605 b began on that date ncboe denied the mcms petition on march 15th and adopted written
findings supporting the denial on april 5 2022 which is within the 90-day timeline required in
statute because of this the cde does not find any procedural violations and therefore does not find
any abusive discretion after reviewing the complete documentary record and supporting
documentation submitted by the parties to this appeal the cde has determined that neither the
nvusd nor ncboe abuse this discretion in reaching their decisions to deny mcms's charter petition
therefore the cde recommends the sbe affirm nvusd's and ncboe's decisions
to deny the mcms charter petition and that concludes my presentation
thank you stephanie uh at this point i'm going to open the public hearing at 10 33 am
we will first hear from petitioners representing my thomas charter middle school
they will have 12 minutes to make their presentation we will then hear from nappa
valley unified school district and the nappa county board of education who denied the charter
appeal the district and county will have a combined total of 12 minutes after the presentation we will
open up the phone line for public comment from individuals who are not part of the presentation
petitioner you may begin
good morning president darling hammon and board members and thank you very much for hearing our
appeal today my name is lauren daley jolene yee and i are the co-petitioners for my commis charter
middle school again we thank you today for your time jolene can you start the slides yes
slides
yes
the proposal for my commis charter middle school or mcms envisions a free neighborhood
school that provides a small school setting for students for whom a large middle school is
problematic the plan is for a school culture steeped in social emotional learning using tools
like daily advisory and a project-based learning model to help students build lasting relationships
and to work collaboratively all students will have individualized learning plans and will assist
in establishing their own educational goals the school is planned to be diverse by design it is
located in downtown nappa near two title one schools to be easily walkable and to serve to
service an underserved neighborhood the school is not designed to be a private school with public
funds nor is it designed to cater to a homogeneous population as you may hear from some callers it is
the exact opposite of that i'd now like to turn it over to john limo john
good morning board members can everyone hear me okay i'm hoping yes um so the staff presentation
i heard um is a little bit dismaying and sort of grossly misstates our appeal there are so many
abuses of process here i can only focus on major ones i'm going to focus on the county and it's
utter failure to uh follow the the procedure in the statute the presumption when a charter is
being considered by a county on appeal or a district is that the agency shall not deny the
petition unless it makes written factual findings specific to the particular petition setting forth
specific facts to support one of the statutory findings there's confusing because there's two
kinds of findings involved here there's eight statutory findings called findings which are the
basis to deny a charter and then if one of those is made by an agency it has to support it with
specific facts to support that finding this has to happen at the same time the board has to make
these factual findings these written factual findings in order to deny in order to deny
that's the that's the due processor that's the key linchpin of the due process you can't have due
process if you make a statutory finding to deny and then cobble together the findings later
um as we stated to you by staff you review now uh these appeals for an abuse of discretion you
selected a or cd has selected a definition that nobody else uses uh but we're stuck with it for
today there are hundreds and hundreds of cases for abuse of discretion that set a different
standard but what's what's at core here is there has to be evidence in the record to support
what the agency did and the agency has to proceed in a procedurally fair manner
next slide please i'm going to talk fast because i only got a few minutes there are multiple
substantial abuses of discretion know that you the state board are the backstop here you are the the
entity uh next slide please let's move on you you are the agency uh that that that calls out an
abuse of discretion and sets the standard so agencies below will not act in an unfair unfair
way i'm going to focus on the county here the substantial evidence in the record and substantial
evidence just means uh the basis for any arbitrary or capricious action so there is there is something
called substantial evidence and there's thousands of cases that describe it in the abuse of
discretion context the county staff report leading up to this action on the appeal was glowing it
said that the charter is comprehensive in detail that the budget is appropriate and viable the
petitioners have met all legal requirements and there's a well established need and demand for
this charter next slide please there's a lot of the staff report about the timing and when timelines
start on the appeal there's no question that and i'll show you it's a screen grab in a second
there's no question that the appeal was submitted to the county on december 21 true a copy of the
petition not the entire appeal packet was not submitted to the district until december 31 it's
a new rule and we missed that you'll hear from the county district about about
error that was an error on march 15th well step back for a second on february 28th the county
issued its first findings which were in support of the charter they didn't recommend approval but
they didn't recommend denial and they said lots of great things about the charter on march 15th
it's indisputed that the board took action to deny it they didn't adopt any written findings
that started our 30-day timeline to appeal we had to file our appeal by april 14th to be in
front of you not until april 5th did the did the county staff cobble together their their findings
to present them to the board nine days before our appeal deadline that's unlawful that's
procedurally unfair next slide please the documentary record is clear that we submitted
on december 21st this is a finding that the county made this is from their april 5th finding
on december 21st they received the petition period next slide please
in relevant part the the statute says we must provide a copy of the petition to the district
at the same time we provided to the county not our entire appeal packet that was provided later
but our petition was provided indisputably to the county excuse me to the district on
december 31st so worst case that's the start date there's citations to the record for you
right there next please they took action to deny the county took action to deny this petition on
march 15th all that was made was this motion i've quoted it here that's the entirety of it
that's the entirety of the action that they took there's no factual findings whatsoever written or
not next slide please
the purported findings were drafted post hoc they were not within the 90-day statutory timeline but
even so they weren't even sufficient they had different findings on february 28th that were
contrary to their april 5th findings we agree with cd staff report that they denied the petition
on march 15th and adopted the findings on april 5th that in and of itself there was nothing else
in the record that demonstrates a violation of the process and timeline and this should be
overturned next slide please the post-hoc findings include many statements that are not supported by
the record i want to say something about this staff said that we didn't cite to the record
but then they quoted the citations that we had we just cited them at the end of our brief and
there's nothing there's nothing wrong with that but the problem here is the absence of evidence
in the record we can't cite the things that don't exist so many of the the facts that were
relied on for the findings were stated by callers on march 15th we had no opportunity to respond
that's that is substantially unfair for example there's no evidence whatsoever that my
comments would substantially undermine existing services academic offerings or problematic
offerings that's finding 21 there's nothing in the record about that it's also false
because there's another finding that they made that's the opposite of that and i encourage you
to look at the february 28th findings and the pages i've cited here also in the findings there's
a finding 24 that said that the district would need to eliminate middle school program and
elementary school music and physical physical education programs there was no board discussion
at the county of that whatsoever it can't be a finding of the board that they deliberated made
that finding similar to 25 saying there was no such discussion next slide myth of the harmless
error you're going to hear from the district in the county they're going to say oh yeah these were
these were just harmless error violations they really don't matter well you've you've staked out
your own definition of of abusive discretion harmless error exists in the 1094.5 judicial
standard for abusive discretion so if you want that standard great i'll take it but anyway the
abuses here were not harmless we were deprived of our right to have the draft the findings that
the county relied on published 15 days in advance they didn't do that we were denied we denied the
charter on march 15th with no written or even spoken findings whatsoever and you just tried
to fix it they tried to fix it weeks later with comments made at march 15th as evidence it's an
ambush it's really what it is and the findings were ratified just days before the appeal deadline
next slide please okay near the backstop here to ensure a fair and lawful process
this is a high quality petition i'll just point to what the county board said and its staff of
report of february 28th its findings and report there's blatant abuses here if you don't reverse
this it's going to be mayhem at the district and county level no one's going to follow a process
because nobody can ever win on appeal here a reversal here will ensure that districts and
counties will provide due process and follow the statutory procedure for would-be petitioners but
charters are supposed to be encouraged that's 47 600 of the statute the most important guiding
principle lauren i'll turn it over to you so john i think i'm taking over thank you president and
esteemed members of the board lauren daly and i have been described as just two moms trying to
start a charter school not competent to file this petition but our resumes demonstrate otherwise
we've consulted with subject matter experts with decades of experience and expertise
and we drafted an exemplary 187 page petition that were far more detailed and extensive than
any other petition actually approved by the district despite our impeccable credentials
we have been chastised and maligned in an attempt to discredit us here are a few choice words from
the hearing on december 9th dr musetti we did not understand basic regulations and requirements
we had a lack of professionalism and incompetency trustee riser our petition read like sort of a
hastily thrown together paper by like a freshman interested in majoring in education trustee
gracia our budget was phony and we were fraudulently attempting to inflate our income these assertions
were directly contradicted by the county staff report when the district uncovered metadata for
school and compton from a document template trustee gracia tried to blow the racial dog whistle
stating i don't know a lot of parents in the nappa valley who would want to send their children to
school in compton using the compton word 14 times during his 20 minute presentation i'm not sure
that trustee gracia's where that nappa student demographics are similar to compton's or that
compton public schools consistently rate higher than nappa on great schools.org it is clear
that the district had no intention of giving us a fair shake if they had there would have been some
pros mixed in with all the cons but the entire staff presentation and the endless minutes of
prepared speeches filled with vitriol not a single person said a single positive comment about the
charter we thought we would have a fair shot the county but we did not we heard that the superintendent
had visited english learner families the week before and told them to call in and tell you
until the county that we were white segregationists taking public dollars for an elitist private
school and 40 parents called in and did just that after hours of this repeated message we
were not surprised by the result last month at the accs hearing the commissioners got a taste of
these theatrics although this time i think we're actually called racist notably one caller stated
that the district had threatened county programs if ncao e approved their charter even though the
county did not approve our charter my understanding is the district has full contracts with the county
and will transfer national nappa special education programs out of ncoe as you vote please consider
our families who've watched two moms stand up again and again hearing after hearing fighting
for public education and what we got in exchange we elected and public officials who called us
names questioned our intelligence and competence and threatened to investigate us for made-up
claims they manipulated their constituents people they are supposed to serve by threatening to cut
their programs and told them to call us racist thank you if the presentation is concluded we
will hear from the napa valley district and the board county board of education
you combined have 12 minutes
and the petitioners stop sharing so that i can share our presentation
good morning thank you for the opportunity to present today my name is rabindraming law
i'm the assistant superintendent of the napa valley university school district along with
me today i have alex sears legal counsel for the napa valley unified school district
and jennifer nix legal counsel for the napa county board of education next slide please
the appeal to the state board lists five grounds and can be summarized as claimed violations of
the timeline evidence to support the findings and the district review process like the cd staff
report finds the napa valley unified school district and nappa county board of education
did not violate any procedures as part of the charter review process and therefore did not
abuse their discretion the process was fair and robust next slide please upon receipt of
the petition the district conveyed a team of 14 staff members to review the petition with
guidance from district legal counsel and the following departments data business services
enrollment human resources instructional services operations special education student services
and technology next slide please the review team established the timeline reviewed appropriate
statutes regulations and resources such as the california charter authorizing professionals
initial charter petition toolkit charter school accounting best practices manual listen to public
testimony utilize utilize an evaluation matrix develop recommendations and the assistant
superintendent of business services and district legal counsel wrote findings of fact as a side
note i'd like to point out that the review team went through every item in the california charter
authorizing professionals initial charter petition toolkit and documented each item this
documentation was included in the administrative record next slide please after a very fair
unbiased and thorough review process the nappa valley board of education took action to deny
the maya thomas charter petition on december 9th 2021 there were four findings for denial and 19
pages of factual findings in support of denial contrary to the petitioner's statement the response
did not refute each and every factual finding by district staff additionally petitioners response
to district staff findings and recommendations would receive less than two hours prior to the
start of the december 9th board meeting next slide please
the remainder of the the remainder of the presentation will be covered by district and
county staff legal counsel alex please continue thank you petitioner's appeal submission as well
as their comments to this board makes a number of assertions that portray the district's review
process as unfair however as the cd staff has correctly found the evidence cited by petitioners
does not demonstrate that nappa valley unified school district review process was unfair
in other words petitioners didn't provide citations to the record to support those assertions
cd staff analysis found no evidence of procedural violations and therefore no abuse of discretion
in fact the primary documents in the record and the additional evidence presented with the
district's opposition show that the district's review process followed the law and that it was
not arbitrary or biased the evidence also shows the petitioners were given ample opportunity to
respond to district staff's questions and to address the staff findings and recommendations
at the district board meeting and also that they were given unlimited time for their presentation
to the district board next slide please with respect to the district's findings cd staff also
found the petitioners failed to meet their burden to show that the district abuses discretion and we
agree with this conclusion just to summarize the appeal challenged only one of the district's four
statutory grounds for denial and only two of the 24 factual findings supporting that ground
the remaining grounds for denial have gone unchallenged remember that only one statutory
finding under 47605 c numbers one through eight is sufficient to justify denying a charter petition
an appeal needs to show how each and every finding was not supported by the evidence
and this appeal fails to make that showing next slide please
ab 1505 is very specific in that once the district and the county have both made their decisions at
the local level those decisions should stand unless it can be proven that there was an abuse of
discretion contrary to petitioners council's contentions in this meeting a quasi legislative
action such as approving or denying a charter school is not subject to the section 1094.5
administrative standard uh administrative mandate standard on review that's for a quasi
adjudicatory action a quasi legislative action is subject to a more deferential review standard
and under this standard the petitioners must not must show not only that there was an abusive
discretion but that they were prejudiced by the local agency actions that they challenge
prejudice means that the challenged action itself resulted in a worse outcome the petitioners would
have received otherwise so even if precisioners could have shown a minor procedural violation
if it didn't change the outcome it cannot justify reversal this appeal presents no evidence to show
how any action by either the district or the county board prejudiced the petitioners for example
their challenge to the county board's timeline fails to show how the county's adoption of the
findings on april 5th resulted in a worse outcome and they cannot make this showing because the
outcome was the same whether the county board adopted findings on march 15th or on april 5th
i will turn the present the presentation over to jennifer nix now to discuss the county board's
review in more detail good morning turning to petitioners arguments against the county board
the record is clear that the county board followed all procedural aspects of the charter schools act
and considering the appeal from nappa valley unified as to their decision and that the process
was procedurally fair as cde staff found the county board of education denied the maya commis
charter middle school petition and adopted supporting factual findings within the 90-day
timeline petitioners submitted their appeal petition to the county superintendent of schools
on december 21st however they did not simultaneously submit their appeal petition to nappa valley
unified school district as required by statute without that submission and notice to the to the
local district the county board did not have jurisdiction to hear the appeal as of december
21st the county did not sit on this issue the county superintendent reached out to petitioners
and let them know that they needed to submit their complete appeal to the nappa valley unified
school district in addition to the county board which they did on january 5th accordingly the
timeline started on that day um this is a really important procedural aspect and it's not one that
that the county board was able to just ignore particularly in this case because the local
school district had concerns that petitioners had changed their petition on appeal and that
remand was necessary given the date of complete submission of the appeal the record is clear that
the county board took action to deny the petition and adopt factual findings in support of that
denial within 90 days of the submission the petitioners are making allegations to the
contrary but those allegations they are not based in fact or law so they're not based on the record
before you they're also not based in law the county board followed what is a common procedure
by directing staff to prepare findings that were in alignment with the record they then
reviewed those findings and had them attested to by the board president prior to having the
full board ratify them those findings that were drafted and adopted did nothing more than reflect
in writing the rationale that the board articulated on the record in the public hearing
the written record here does include the public hearing itself and does include all of the
documentation that was submitted to the board that they reviewed for that public hearing this
process is permitted in law and it's permitted in county board policy and there's nothing that
is contrary to that process in the charter schools act the charter schools act requires
that the board make written factual findings but it doesn't specify that those findings have to be
adopted at the same meeting at which the decision is made or that the petitioners have a right to
get copies of those findings 15 days in advance to to say otherwise would effectively require the
county board to adopt a staff report and it would take away the county board's discretion in making
a decision and it would take away the county board's discretion to disagree with the staff
report that's particularly problematic here because the county board of education doesn't
actually have staff to make recommended findings right as you know the county board and the county
superintendent of schools are two separately elected bodies and the county superintendent
of schools runs the county office of education i do also want to note that even had the county
board exceeded the 90-day timeline that timeline is not mandatory in the law the the education code
in section 46 47605 subdivision k6 specifically provides that the county board can act on the
petition all the way through 180 days after receipt of that petition moreover and and i do
think this is important it's undisputed that this process did not actually harm petitioners at no
time did they contact anybody within the county office or the county board or legal counsel to
raise concerns with the way the process was was rolling out despite that they had been in contact
with legal counsel and with the county throughout the process regarding other procedural aspects
and also in in their petition appeal materials they don't present any argument of harm or
prejudice today they did present three arguments with regard to harm or prejudice but those those
arguments also aren't borne out by the factual record the findings were provided to them much
in advance of april 5th and they have given themselves a a date by which they had to appeal
the decision but that's not a date that that anybody has argued is the date they did have to
actually appeal that decision so there also was no harm from the procedure that the county board
followed mr schultz could i get the next slide please i also want to touch on an allegation
that's made in the appeal materials that the county board's findings were insufficient
because this allegation is demonstrably false the county board made 26 detailed findings of it
to support its decision the findings included citations to specific facts in the record
and as cde found the petitioners are not arguing that the findings were arbitrary
capricious or entirely lacking evidentiary support they don't actually challenge the
evidentiary basis for the county board's findings instead they argue regarding the weight that the
county board gave to facts in the record which is not a cognizable argument in this abusive
discretion review next slide please so in conclusion we are asking you to affirm the
denials of the charter petition notably the law permits the state board to affirm the determination
of the school district's governing board or to affirm the county board or to affirm both and
that's that's in subdivision k2c and i listening to the charter school's presentation
their arguments are entirely against the county board so we do not believe that there is an
argument of abusive discretion against either the local district or the county board of education
however i urge you to consider that you can affirm one or the other decision or both we do have
representatives from both lea is present to answer any questions that you have regarding
this matter thank you for your time we look forward to speaking with you if you have questions
thank you for those presentations and at this point we'll hear
we'll open the phone line for the public comment queue
so can we get the public comment slide up on the screen
public comment is limited to one minute and is for people who are not part of either presentation
so looking for the public comment slide there it comes members of the public are wishing to
provide comment may do so by calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the
slide that is shown now we encourage you to please state your name and affiliation for the
record please remember to turn down the speaker volume of your computers if you are following the
live feed speakers will be limited to one minute and speakers meeting Spanish translation will be
given two minutes to incorporate that translation i'd like to ask the translator to provide the
instructions in Spanish for callers needing translation of the request so is there any public
comment
okay we will open up the phone line now it looks like we have about 17 callers in the queue
good morning caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time starts now
good morning madam president and members my name is cassie mancini and i'm here on behalf of the
california school employees association urging the fe to affirm the district and county board's
decisions to deny the maya commis charter middle school petition csa wholeheartedly agrees with
the staff recommendation the staff report thoroughly impacts each of the petitioner's claims and
explains why they did not constitute an abuse of discretion or why the petitioner did not offer
sufficient evidence of an abuse of discretion so i won't restate those in my remarks however i will
emphasize that the board should consider the intent of ab 1505 when considering this appeal
the intent of the law was to give deference to local communities and local decision makers
for the state board to take the extreme step of overriding a local decision an abuse of discretion
must be so egregious that its consequences mean that but for that abuse the charter would have
been granted that is clearly not the case here therefore we urge the fe to affirm the local
decision thank you thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
you have one minute your time starts now hello this is hannah henry from nappa i am a parent
of four children who have attended public school in nappa i want to urge the board to affirm the
decision of nbusd and the county board in denying the maya commis petition this is taking resources
away from individuals from the school district from potential students and families alone but
beyond that this has been thoroughly vetted and reviewed i have been part of some of those reviews
and it it is unfair the accusations made against nbusd are wholly unfair a tremendous amount of
work is being done to listen to the community and create k-8 programs a arts influenced
bilingual program for middle schools there's independent study there are plenty of options
and we should be devoting our energy to enriching those options and supporting our school system
thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you
have one minute your time starts now
my name is kim snes and i'm a community member and a parent in nappa i have two children who
are in high school in nappa right now one is at nutek i want to appreciate the board hearing this
appeal i'm calling to voice my support for my campus charter middle school for a few reasons
we need this innovative model in nappa they're embracing the science of learning and development
in a way the district is not able to do given their fiscal situation they're going to have
a smaller learning community where children are seen and known which is important my daughter's
gay both of my children need this sort of smaller diverse environment they won't benefit from my
account but i want other community members too they're going to have a later start individual
learning plans all kinds of things the district cannot offer i believe nbusd did abuse their
discretion they defined community solely on the basis of a fiscal impact that would change the
employment of their employment roles if parents and students choose my account the school of course
will also employ teachers so what would happen is teachers might move from the roles of nappa unified
over to the charter school and those teachers are incredibly important thank you your time is up
next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts
now
hi my name is jay finison i'm a parent and a community member of nappa i was a member of one
of the schools that was closed it had a model very similar to my account we were not consulted
whatsoever in the decision to close our school this is a very important fdl model that was
created 20 years ago had a huge following had a huge waiting list and there was absolutely no
compromise whatsoever with this district and as a result i know over 100 families that pulled their
kids which resulted in a huge loss of ada of parents who went to private instead of sitting
in our public schools and keeping them strong so if you're talking about financial or fiscal
responsibility that was not followed in this case there were other options there was more
compromise that could have been said and they you guys not listening to the parents is that your
peril those people are bailing the public thank you right and left in this community thank you your
time is up next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
my name is justin godi as a parent of nz usd students i ask you deny the my account's petition
you may hear many today talk about the impact of this charter would have on our children
i'm going to be honest with you i'm not concerned about my children i'm white i'm middle class and
i'm privileged that i can afford to supplement my children's education regardless of the outcome
my children will be fine i'm here to talk about the children who are not being represented about
the families that can't take time off on a thursday to speak here this charter is not being proposed
by struggling working class and largely latinx families that make up most of this district this
charter is being pushed forward by other privileged white middle class families like myself
families that can supplement their children's education this charter would take money from
an already struggling district in order to recreate services for one small demographic
taking from the many to give to the few by replicating systems the district has already
created this charter is not in the best interest to my community as a whole please deny this appeal
thank you for your time consideration thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record you have one minute your time starts now
good morning president darling hammond vice president glubberwood and his speaking board
members this is jena plate on behalf of the california charter schools association
i am eager to express our support of my commons charter middle school and respectfully ask as
outlined in our letter submitted friday that you reverse the local denial of this program
these petitioners along with the students and families they intend to serve have been
the subject of a disregard of their rights at the local level we are in the early stages of working
through the implications of ab 1505 given that this body has the obligation to offer every
possible consideration when faced with students and families that are asking for educational
options beyond what is currently available to them we respectfully ask that you reverse
the local decision to deny my commons charter middle school thank you thank you next caller
please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
caller ending in the last four digits 5422 you are live please start your public comment now
uh yes uh thank you very much uh this is jerry brown uh as you know i was governor of california
but also attorney general and i followed with great interest uh the legal discussions here
and it is disappointing that the educational quality and educational opportunity is now mired
in legal wrangling among the lawyers this case is pretty clear to me uh the board
is pretty clear to me the board you're the board of justice and the board of inclusion
this is a great charter i've read the report it's unique it's going to have individualized
learning it's sensitive to low-income people and charges about racism are just outrageous so
the bottom line here legally the denials below are arbitrary arbitrary is what abuse of discretion
is at its essence this is a good school the county staff noted how valuable it will be
and the cost to the district over 10 years they're speculating that instead of going down 17 percent
because of the fall off an ada it may get down 19 percent 10 years and yet that's a very small
amount over a long period of time giving the district a lot of ways to adjust look the charter
schools were created to create a stimulus to the public schools to create options for families
here you have some active parents in nappa trying to do right by their kids bringing in new technology
small school small classes very individual this is a great charter if you guys apologize governor
but the time is up down it's the death knell of charter schools please reverse this really bad
decision it's arbitrary and i'm confident the courts will uphold your judgment thank you very
much thank you thank you very much next caller please state your name and affiliation for the
record you have one minute your time starts now
so
go ahead and start your public comment
this is clare crofford within the public interest ab 1505 allows districts to make decisions about
what is in the interest of the most students in their jurisdiction nappa county advised nv usd
to take steps to remain fiscally solvent including addressing the high cost of small schools
to support a stable educational system for all students the district made the difficult decision
to close their smallest middle school river middle the mtms supporters are clear their intent is to
recreate this option for a small number of students river serves by far the lowest percentage of high
need students serving significantly lower percentages of socioeconomically disadvantaged
and homeless students english learners and students with disabilities and all other middle schools in
the district overall river maintained a majority white student body in a district with less than
30 white student population only moving the needle slightly in the last years under district
management river has significantly lower percentages of latino students in a majority
latino district the petitioners are trying to make this confusing but it is very clear
authorizers may consider the negative impact that potential churches have on all students
thank you very much next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you
have one one minute your time starts now
hello hello hello hello please start your public comment now i would ask that the translators please
translate into spanish
okay
please
Good morning, my name is Pati Terrones, resident and mother
of students in the public school system in Napa. My vote is no in regards to opening
Mayakama school. We need to be conscious on the negative impact on the education and economics
that this school will affect public schools within the district of Napa. Opening a school,
for students only with exclusive privileges looks to me like a very childish and selfish
tantrum. It would only affect the programs that we currently have with our students in
public schools. My vote is no. As a Hispanic mother, I keep saying no in regards to opening
this school and I'm against any social economic discrimination. Thank you. Next caller, please
state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
I would ask for the translators to also please translate into Spanish.
I am here. My name is Irma Sanchez.
I'm so sorry. I'm going to ask her to come closer to the mic.
I don't agree that you opened the Mayakama school because it would affect my children.
I'm sorry, the rest was a little bit far. I'm going to have to ask her to get off of speaker.
That was my comment. She said. Okay, thank you so much. Next caller, please state your name and
affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello. Is the translator on the line?
Can you speak out loud please? I need you to come closer and speak out loud please. State your name.
I believe that we have the caller has dropped. We will move on to the next caller. Next caller,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello. Is the translator on the line?
Okay.
This will destroy our
Okay. This will destroy our
educational system
We've done a lot of work
We've done a lot of work the last two years
the last two years
and we just found more
two years. We do not need another school. My son has an ID. Up until now he has used
all of the services from the District. Mayakama would only support 400 students and the District
has 1,600 students. I say no to Mayakama. Thank you very much. Next caller, please state
your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Next caller, ending with the last four digits, 9538, you are live. Please start your public
comment now. Good morning, President Darden-Hammond, members of the California Board of Education.
My name is Pat Andrew Jennings and I serve as the Assistant Superintendent of Instructional
Services for the Napa Valley School District. In the fall of 2021, my staff participated
in a comprehensive and thorough review of the Mayakama Charter Petition. I am confident
in the rigorous review completed by the NDUSD staff, which determined that the practical
implementation of the stated educational methodologies was not well described in the petition. Additionally,
NDUSD has a variety of middle school options to meet the needs of diverse learners, including
three comprehensive middle schools, one smaller language and cultural arts integration middle
school, and two TK through eight grade schools. As a result of our findings, we recommend
the denial of the petition on the grounds that the educational program set forth in
the petition was not reasonably comprehensively described and was a duplication of district
programming. I respectfully request that the State Board of Education deny the appeal before
that. Thank you. Thank you. And we have a quick request. Sorry. This is an interpreter
and I was asked to make a quick announcement in Spanish for those who could not be heard
properly. If that's okay, if I may. Please go ahead. Thank you. Okay. I was asked to
say. Thank you very much. Okay. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for
the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now. Caller ending with the last four
digits 4172. You are live. Please start your public comment now.
Thank you very much. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now. Caller ending the last four digits 2442. You
are live. Please start your public comment. Okay. I think they have either dropped off.
We'll move on. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now. My name is Heidi and the parent. As an involved
in the parent, I followed this charter application process from the beginning. And from the beginning,
it was clear that the charter does not propose to do anything new or novel that is not already
provided to our students. In fact, it would unfairly pull significant resources away from
the 16,000 students in the district, including my own children, to support just 100 of so kids
with a quasi special program. There are duplicate social, emotional programs and small school
environments already in the district at the middle school level. I am worried that this
proposed charter does not serve the best needs of our community as a whole. And the result would be
other programs and other schools could be impacted. My assessment is that the Napa Valley Unified
School District and Napa County Board of Education both did the right thing by denying the charter,
did so within their scope. It is clear that the CDE staff report completely agrees that the
district and county did not act in any way that abuse their discretion when they both denied the
charter. I hope you will consider these facts in making your decision to to affirm the denial of
the charter. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the
record. You have one minute. Your time starts now. Hi, my name is Gail Young and I am president of
Napa Valley Educators Association. I'm a teacher and a parent of two students who have graduated
from Napa Valley Unified School District and have successful careers. Please deny this petition.
There was no abuse of discretion by the district or the county. Both district and county agreed
the approval of this school would have a negative fiscal impact and community impact.
Please follow the intent of AB 1505 and deny this petition. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is David T. Gracia, trustee for NBUSD. We followed a rigorous process and staff did an
impressively thorough review of the charter application. The petitioners in contrast were
not impressive in their presentation. They pre-recorded their presentation and didn't speak
much at the meeting, remaining mostly silent. They refused to meet with district staff and
submitted a 20-page document to the board by email about one and a half hours before the meeting
we were set to decide the petition. Similarly, the petitioners were treated by NCOE with velvet
gloves and staff bent over backwards to give them every opportunity to succeed, even going so far
as to have staff not make a recommendation to the board. Still, the petition was defeated. I ask that
you uphold the decisions of both NBUSD and NCOE. There was no abuse of discretion and petitioners
were treated fairly at both levels. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hello, this is Marisa.
Hello, I am Marisa and I have a translator.
Do you have a translator?
Yes.
Okay.
I have a son who studied in the Napa district as one of the best students and was accepted by one of the best universities in the country, Berkeley.
Now he is studying his postgraduate degree. He is a fruit of the Napa district. He is a teacher
in one of the district schools where he is also a special education doctor in the Napa district.
I do not agree in opening Mayacama because we have a new option in Unidos Middle School
where a love philosophy is practiced that means taking care of the sense of belonging,
and our students need this for their minds. I do not support Mayacamas. Equality for all.
Hello, my name is Marisa.
I have a son that studied at NBUSD as one of the best students of the district. He was accepted
in one of the best universities in the country, UC Berkeley. He is now studying his master's.
He is a result of the education he received at NBUSD. He is now teaching at schools in the
district where he also acts as an interpreter and a bridge for special ed. I do not agree to the
opening of Mayacama's middle school. We have now a great new option which is Unidos Middle School
where they practice a philosophy of cario which means caring for the students feeling of belonging
where they want students to feel welcome at home and safe. That is what our students need.
I do not support Mayacama's opening. Equidad para todos, equity for all.
Thank you. Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one moment one minute your time starts now.
Hello good morning my name is Osorio Morales.
Okay she has her own interpreter. Okay thank you.
Please proceed.
So
Hi, we have to focus these dollars on programs that benefit our students not opening another
school.
My two daughters are English learners at Willow School and they received everything they needed
English learners.
I am not in favor of Mayakama's opening.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Steve Green, parent.
Both the district and county boards of education told NVUSD that to preserve programming it
had to close inefficient small schools to avoid state receivership because of falling
revenues from declining enrollment.
NVUSD did that.
It was painful.
American Canyon gave up a promised new middle school.
Napa lost small, elementary, and middle schools.
NVUSD is fiscally solvent which saved programming.
The Mayakama's proponents want to force NVUSD to authorize a duplicative, inefficient small
school.
Small classes, smaller middle school settings, duplicated by K-8 and Napa.
Programs and social-emotional learning, duplicated.
All duplicated.
District comprehensive overall and our American Canyon middle school in particular offer better
education than what's proposed.
Call our American Canyon kids and degrade their education.
Please vote no.
Do not degrade our kids' learning and with all respect, Jerry Brown doesn't know our
community.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning, California Board of Education.
My name is Norm Ortiz.
I am a parent of an eighth grader at Redwood Middle School.
A rigorous, grand, unique opportunity within NVUSD that serves many students in our community.
Today's conversation should not be in any way political.
All students should have an opportunity to receive the education of their choice, whether
it be in public schools or charters.
Being California one of the most prosperous states in our country financially speaking,
the California Department of Education should continue to work closely to a lot more funding,
resources for programs, services, and instruction to address the learning gaps and needs especially
of social economic disadvantage impacted students such as English language learners, special
education students, and foster youth.
Quality variety of educational opportunities as already stated in previous board meetings.
I am not against charter schools based on the information provided submitted, which
is part of the record.
It is my understanding based on my interpretation of the facts.
It is not the best timing to approve it.
I sincerely hope the right decision is reached today and that we continue to build community
and fairness to all.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
Okay.
Thank you very much,
staff.
Spanish-speaking parents at American Canyon Middle School.
In my opinion, my commas from the viewpoint has, excuse me, in my opinion, the district
currently has declining enrollment and my commas would be a consideration that I would
make to open.
It is not necessary to open more schools.
To the contrary, we need to put better efforts into our current schools.
If the current education that students are receiving by, that students are receiving
other parents feel is not adequate, then there are private institutions that can satisfy
those expectations.
No to my commas.
Thank you.
Next caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
My name is Marie Dyatt.
I'm a parent and trauma-informed healthcare provider at NAPA.
As stated before, NBUSD has and continues to create harm in the community by working
persistently to block my commas from opening.
The environment my commas strives to provide is desperately needed in our community.
NBUSD shows a blatant pattern of unseparately worthy financially driven and unethical behavior
which necessitates this appeal.
They use threats, spread rumors, promote community structure and overlook community needs.
Additional evidence to this claim is the recent closure of an extremely unique and
valued veteran special education program for preschoolers.
NBUSD has absorbed these children and their financial benefit into their own program despite
doing any of the ethical preparation needed to make the transition like this.
They don't listen to the parents of the children whose program serves.
They blatantly stated that they didn't care if they didn't have to support it because
they didn't have to legally.
That says a lot about the way NBUSD functions and it is not for the benefit of the children
or parents to whom it serves.
Thank you, your time is up.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Andres Ramirez and I am providing more than 16,000 students where the district
supports multi-language learners, special education students, after school.
16,000 students will impact them because they will have a higher education level, they will
be better students, parents and citizens.
250 to 300 charters is a lot of opportunities that our own 16,000 students will have.
We don't need to better the opportunities for our children, inclusivity and not exclusion.
I do not support my comment.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Sylvia Avalos and I am providing more than 16,000 students where the district
supports multi-language learners, special education students, after school.
Hi, my name is Sylvia.
Why open another school in the county if we have had to close many other schools?
It is important to focus on all of the 16,000 students currently in the district.
Why separate or segregate so many children just for something unnecessary that will have
a big cost to our families and the district?
No to my account.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello.
Bueno, me escucha?
Si, si la escuchamos.
Cul es tu nombre, por favor?
Puede decir tu nombre, por favor?
Claro que si.
Estarion Mondragon?
Ah, no, I don't need a traduccin.
Thank you.
And thank you for your interest in opening Mayacama in our county, but we don't need
it.
We have great schools that are no classes discriminatory and elitist.
Here are simply seen as per place, not of the best interest for our students.
It is important to leave behind political and monetary interest.
Here is important to take into account 50,000 students, not to 350 students.
Please, Mayacama.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
As board president of the NVUSD Board of Education, I would like to highlight that this charter
petition was denied for very specific factual findings, including the community impact in
inaccurate financial projections.
There are ethical components to financial decisions.
There was no abuse of discretion and emotional pleas are not facts.
It is our collective responsibility to create equitable environments for all of our students.
This charter does not do so.
The dilutive effect an additional school has on a declining enrollment district is akin
to siphoning public fund dollars.
Reduction or elimination of resources and programming for thousands of middle school
students is a legitimate impact.
The charter would serve a narrow portion of public school students.
The composition of petition signatures does not represent the unduplicated count they
have tried to recruit, but need to validate their revenue projections.
This charter does not mirror our community.
We need to thoughtfully consider if this charter with a high risk profile will adequately
serve children.
And if the school is not successful, the reality is the children absorb the impact.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
I have read the opposition to the proposal and have been listening to the lawyers talk
about timelines and disrespect the petitioners.
It seems very strange to me that no one references the kids, their education, or their mental
health.
My economist is embracing the science of learning and development.
My kids thrived with smaller learning communities.
Aren't we supposed to be in this for the kids?
They need options that work for them.
Please support this school for the children.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
My name is Holly Zaccone.
I have two children attending school in the Napa School District, a daughter in 12th grade
and a son in 6th grade.
Both are in dual language immersion programs.
As an NBUSD parent, I'm asking that you deny the Maya Commons charter petition.
My kids, along with 16,000 other Napa students, will be negatively impacted.
Losing 300 students to a charter school will greatly affect the school district's budget.
The last thing my kids and other Napa students need right now, after some academic losses
due to the pandemic, is to lose some programs related to dual immersion and the performing arts because of budget cuts.
If you approve this petition, my kids, along with their friends at school, are in danger of losing some of their educational experiences
that are important to their future and their academic successes.
This charter is definitely not in the best interest of our Napa community.
Thank you for your serious consideration.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
My name is Terri Lynn Racetti, and I am the Executive Director of Special Education for Napa Valley Unified School District.
I have concerns with the charter application based upon the vagueness of the plan with regards to meeting the needs of students identified with disabilities.
The plan references seeking admittance to a SELPA and then states that it would be its own LEA.
However, the only special education job identified was that of a special education teacher.
This leaves out many key IEP team members who are necessary to meet the needs of this group of students.
In addition, the plan lacks specificity to distinguish between the needs of students with disabilities as opposed to the needs of the multilingual learner.
It allocates only 45 minutes daily in totality to meet the needs of this group of students.
This is not sufficient.
Finally, the plan does not allow any flexibility for students with more intensive disabilities,
such as those who require additional instruction for mental or behavioral health needs or for those with low incidence disabilities,
all of which there are high numbers within the Napa Valley community.
I recommend that you deny this application.
Thank you. Your time is up. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Good morning. David from CSCA representing classified school employees in Napa and across California and co-sponsors of AB 1505.
You've heard a lot about the merits or demerits of the proposed charter.
But as you know, that's not the question today.
As you've heard from your staff, this is a hearing about whether there was abuse of discretion for procedural errors to rise to the level of abuse of discretion.
Such errors would have to be so egregious as to amount to procedural unfairness.
In this case, your staff found no procedural violations based on the requirements of the law.
Therefore, if you trust the analysis of your staff, as I do, you should not reverse the decisions of the local boards on these grounds.
MCMS also alleges that factual findings of the local elected officials were insufficient to deny the charter.
Even if you take that argument on its face, it is not the state board's role to weigh whether the evidence is sufficient.
As your staff made clear in order to find abuse of discretion,
you'd have to find that the evidentiary record was entirely lacking, meaning there are no facts supporting the school district's conclusions.
The petitioning charter has not even made that allegation.
They therefore cannot meet the abuse of discretion standard and both school districts' decisions should be affirmed.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Good morning.
My name is Michael Juba and I'm a classroom teacher representing the California Teachers Association.
The primary purpose of AB 1505 was to return control of charter schools authorizing to local school districts.
CDE staff state on page four of the item that based on CDE's review of the appeal and the documentary record,
Maya Commons has not met the burden of detailing with specific citations to the documentary record how Napa Valley Unified or Napa County Board of Education
abused their discretion in the denial of the charter petition.
The district and the county board both acted in accordance with the law in denying the charter petition.
We urge SBE to support the CDE's recommendation to affirm Napa Valley Unified and Napa County Board's decision to deny the Maya Commons charter petition.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello, it's Eric Premack with the Charter Schools Development Center.
If it's one thing we're learning today is that we're all navigating some very poorly drafted appeal statutes without clarity about some key terms, processes and standards.
Notwithstanding this lack of vital clarity, the rather glaring procedural errors by both the district and county boards clearly violated the key provisions of the statute in question here.
Given these huge errors, we believe that the state board is obliged to make a finding that an abuse of discretion clearly occurred at both the district and county levels.
We also believe the charter position has considerable merit as affirmed by county staff and that the denial at the local level should be reversed.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller with the last four digits 3800.
You are live.
Please start your public comment now.
Hi, my name is Alan Cameron.
I have family members who are graduates of the Napa Valley Unified School District, and I would like to lend my voice in support of the charter school application.
I agree with Jerry Brown and it's a great opportunity with the new school to introduce new innovations and technology, which are moving very rapidly.
California, of course, is leading in these areas and charter school would provide opportunities to use that new technology.
There's big needs caused by the pandemic and lots of innovation to recover from the effects of the pandemic and there's federal funding available to support innovations in school safety and new technology.
So I'd like to support the charter school idea.
My name begins Alan Cameron.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
You have one minute.
Caller with the last four digits 6535.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment now.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Caller with the last four digits 7084.
You are now live.
Please start your public comment now.
Yes.
Good morning.
Can you hear me?
We can.
Okay.
Great.
Thank you.
Yes.
Good morning.
My name is Julia and I am here on behalf of here elementary school along with the rest of the community in support of not approving the Maya commerce charter school elementary school is our home.
My daughter is a seventh grade currently a seventh grader and has been there since kinder.
My son graduated from sheer elementary school.
I respectfully disagree because I believe it will have a detrimental impact for our NBUSD students since it does not serve the best interest of the entire community.
I truly believe that it does not foster inclusiveness and diversity.
The other the other piece to this is also it will divert resources away from school and NBUSD students.
It will duplicate services being offered.
Thank you.
Your time is up.
Next caller.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record.
We have one minute.
Your time starts now.
I'm sorry.
We're unable to hear you.
Could you please state your name for.
I'm sorry.
You're not listening.
Me.
Yes I don't.
I'm sorry.
Me.
Yes I don't.
Sorry.
Me.
I'm sorry.
Yes.
Me.
I'm sorry.
Pardon.
Me.
Yes.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
tambin en mi opinin al abrir otra escuela habra menos recursos en el
distrito faltando esos estudiantes que se iran a esta nueva escuela y no estoy
de acuerdo y no se me hace justo el bien de unos y el mal de otros estudiantes
hi my name is Eva Angelina I don't support the opening of maya camas why do
we need a new school if we are closing schools for lack of enrollment it is
just not logic by opening another school that NBUSD will be left with less
resources since those resources will follow the students live in the district
I do not agree I believe it's unfair to care for the for the well-being of some
students and not look for the well-being of all students in the district no to
thank you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you
have one minute your time starts now president Arlene Hammond and members of
the California State Board of Education my name is Monica Reddy and I serve as
a director of curriculum instruction and English learner services for NBUSD as a
member of the NBUSD charter review team I reviewed the educational program with
specific attention to EL services as the NBUSD is composed of 22.6% of
English learners as stated in the NBUSD finding the fact that petitioners are
demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the educational program
outlined especially as it pertains to EL year one and two of implementation of
the petition lacks significant attention to EL's expecting the head of school to
coordinate EL services on top of their job duties yet the job description for
the head of schools does not require background in EL services additionally
this is an unrealistic expectation in year one and two of the job second GLAD
is the main strategy for addressing the needs of EL's yet the petitioners do not
address GLAD in the professional development plan GLAD training is seven
to ten days yet the PD plan is ten days with sixteen pedagogical methods which
is an unreasonable and unrealistic staff expectation lastly the EL reclassification
program monitoring system fails to provide a process nor does it provide
detail regarding the tools and training that will be used thank you for your
careful consideration of the needs of all students and families within NBUSD by
upholding the CDE staff recommendation and denial of the appeal thank you next
caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have one
minute your time starts now hi my name is Alicia Cronbach I'm a parent of a
Napa student and also a resident of Napa County I'd like to say that bully
will never say they're a bully when a bully comes to a position of power it's
harder for those being bullied in this case MCS is petitioned to prove the
behavior I believe strongly the proposed MCM MCMS school is a viable option that
is both fiscally responsible and a diverse school that replaces both
traditional and charter public options that have been stripped away in the last
five years including a walkable neighborhood school that served
primarily EL students I respectfully request that the board approve the
petition for a charter school the MCMS Charter School in Napa thank you thank
you next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record you have
one minute your time starts now
caller ending in with the last four digits three seven one five you are now
live please start your public comment
say what
to listen to most bueno si mi nombre es Sanchez y tengo mi propio intrprete
ok yama si mis hijos acuden a una escuela pblica son dos nias con
necesidades especiales si abren otra escuela van a quitar fondos a nuestra
escuela y eso afectara a mis hijos ya que en sus programas ellos reciben a
diferentes programas porque ellos necesitan mucho esos programas y para
ello no estoy a favor de que abran maya camas porque eso afectara su nivel
acadmico
hi my name is Edma Sanchez good morning my kids attend a public school I have
two boys with special needs if you open my akama's it will take away funding
from public schools that will affect my kids learning and the programs that they
have access to to keep them on a good academic level besides the support that
they receive with their special needs I am not in favor of opening my akama's
as it will only help 300 students thank you thank you next caller please state
your name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
hello hello
tengo mi propia interpretacin mi nombre es elva marquez madre de tres estudiantes
en el sitio escolar de napa en the usb si tiene un programa para apoyar a
nios que quieran estar en un lugar ms ms pequeo que son los programas de tk
octavo grado en brown valley and sheer nb usb tambin of frese a muchos
recursos que pueden apoyar emocionalmente a nuestros estudiantes
desde los centros de recursos familiares los centros de bienestar hay un una
era un programa taller de herramientas emocionales tambin ofrecen durante la
clase los crculos de comunidad y tambin clases de auditoria donde los
nios pueden reunirse esta idea de que el distrito no est ofreciendo los
programas que maya camas est tratando de implementar es falso es importante que
estos fondos se requieran para los programas actuales y las escuelas
actuales no para empezar algo nuevo que solo beneficiara a unos cuantos
estudiantes so nb usb oh i'm sorry my name is elva marquez and i am the parent
of three students within the school nbu school district nb usb does have and
provide a small school setting for middle schoolers it's a tk through a
program in brown valley and sheer nb usb also has a large amount of social
emotional support within their schools they have family resource centers
wellness centers there's also an emotional tool kit that is implemented
in every school we offer community circles during school class and for
middle schoolers and high schoolers there's an advisory class it is
important that the funds that we do have are implemented in the current
program and this idea that maya camas will offer something different that is
not already in place within nb usb it's a lie it will only be able to support a
small amount of the community where the rest of the community if they can only
support less than 400 students thank you thank you next caller please state your
name and affiliation for the record you have one minute your time starts now
caller ending with the last four digits five three eight two you are now live
please start your public comment
the uniform
hello
Yes, we can interpret it.
Okay, thank you.
Please say your name and then your comment.
My name is Edith Pina.
What? Edith Pina?
My name is David Pina.
No, it's Baby Pina.
It's Baby?
It's Baby.
E-S-B-E-I-D-Y.
Pina.
It's Baby Pina.
Baby Pina.
Okay, hello, my name is Stavy Pina.
Pina.
I think she's talking.
Take a flower.
Yes, please say your name.
Can I talk now?
Yes, you can talk.
I'm talking to...
I want to add
that I don't agree with the
Mayakama Charter
because it's not a really inclusive
program because the opportunity
would be for a few children.
Currently, as they said
in another previous comment,
there are already programs that
they are supposedly offering.
Somehow I feel...
Wait, wait.
I'm sorry, I do not agree with
opening the Mayakama.
Actually, just for a few children.
Okay, continue.
I feel frustrated
to see that
because of the capriciousness of some
people
from a high elite,
many children from the middle and
lower classes are going to
be without many resources.
I thought that there was no
corruption in this country
like in Mexico, but with all
that has been happening,
I think...
Wait a minute.
In the community, who have
higher sources of income
are not allowing
some of us with lower and middle
incomes for our children's education.
Continue, please.
I feel that this program is a
racist program and that we are being
discriminated at a large
proportion within this community.
And I ask that
you properly analyze this project
because I do not believe that it is
for the good of the community.
I believe that if you
take this decision, it must be for
the good of the community, not just a few.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your
name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time
starts now.
Good afternoon. My name is
Wendy Agen-Seminges, parent of
a special education middle school
student, rapidly declining
student achievement and a one-size-fits-all
model within MVSD and
their special education support system
has left me with the only option to
remove my special education student
from MVSD. I was
hopeful my commas would be approved in time
for my son to start this fall.
However, there is still an opportunity for all
MVSD middle schoolers to benefit from
this innovative program, open
to all and not available at any public
school in Napa Valley.
The Association of Medical American
Educators Journal states the most
powerful predictor of change in reading and math
in all models was decreasing the student
teacher ratio with larger gains
especially for Hispanic and low special
education services. My commas
fills this need. I feel
certain that MCMS would have not only
met my son's special education needs with
their innovative education plans but would have
helped him thrive. I implore you to
support the my commas charter middle school
petition.
Thank you. Next
caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi, my name is Will
Daley. I am a parent
of a Napa
school system child.
You know, we hear
lots of accusations of racism
and what not. Those are misplaced.
There's no
coincidence that a lot of people protesting
my commas have the exact
same talking points. They've been handed them
by the administration that is trying to make
this about race. It's not.
It's actually about providing an
opportunity for Napa
to institute an innovative program
that hopefully will get fed back into the school.
The administration doesn't want to hear
it. They don't want to hear from parents
about why they're taking their kids out of the
school system.
Unfortunately, we're stuck in
a vicious cycle.
It's going to keep happening. We're going to keep losing people.
Because of the sort of intimidation
that's going on by the administration,
it's not a racist school. It's
designed for everyone. Thank you very much.
Thank you. Next caller, please state
your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Hello. My name is Anne Swinburne
and I'm a charter school policy expert
with the California Teachers Association.
And I am also
an expert on the requirements of AB 1505.
I have followed
the MCMS petition from the very beginning
and it is very clear that this appeal
should be denied by the State Board of Education
for all the good reasons that the CDE,
the district, and the county have cited.
The petitioners and their attorneys
are doing a very strong job of attempting to
confuse or make murky what is a very
straightforward issue. There was no
abuse of discretion committed by either
the district or the county.
Please don't allow the courtroom tactics you're
experiencing from the petitioners and their team
to sway you. The law is clear.
Please deny this appeal as
AB 1505 intended. Thank you.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts now.
Hi. My name is Sylvia Regalado-Zacklott.
I am a parent of the Napa Valley Unified
School District having kids
currently in
K through 9th grade
schools
here. I think one thing
is really evidently clear.
Our school system is not funded
to the level that the state should be
funding it at, and it's instead
dividing families and communities
because that funding is not
available so that we can incorporate
all of these really great programs.
I would like to express
that I would like to see the charter denied.
I believe that the district
made due diligence, the county
made its due diligence, heard from
community members about
how funding would be diverted
away from our schools for all
and being able to implement programs.
Instead, I would like
to see the state and this board's
efforts consolidated
towards working with local
school districts and counties so that our
school systems can be funded to the levels
that they need to be funded so that our
teachers and our students can thrive
and all of our other kids in our
community throughout California can
thrive as well. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time
starts now.
Good afternoon,
state board members. My name is
Nivna Castrejon. I am the president and CEO
of the California Charter Schools Association
and I'm very familiar
with the terms of 1505
as they radically transformed the
way in which charter schools
could continue to be
authorized by
all of the authorizers across the state.
I certainly understand that there
is some confusion in many ways
around how schools should be authorized
and what the abuse of
discretion standard is.
But let me be clear, as having
been a party to those negotiations,
it is absolutely clear that the North
Star of charter schools
existing for and in
response to the needs of
families who are here petitioning
for an
establishment of a school that meets their
needs and broadens the appeal
of choices and opportunities for all
students
is of paramount importance here. 1505
is clear on what
the standards of
evidence that districts and authorizers
must present. They simply
have not met that standard.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time starts
now.
My name is Deirdre Wheeler and I am an
alumni of California public schools
including UC Berkeley. I'm also an
advocate of public education.
I've lived in Napa since 2008
and have two children in the school district
and all I can say is that I have
completely lost my faith in our educational
system because of how the district
and county have behaved over the
last couple of years, including
in regards to this charter school in particular.
Enrollment is sharply declining
because of the district and its actions.
Denying this charter has
only made it worse and will continue to.
I very much support my
comments. We need it in our community.
It has a quality
educational program and it's very
equitable, sorely needed in this
community. Please don't lose
any more families over this because
it is happening because we
do not have good schools in our
district and are only getting worse.
Thank you very much.
Thank you. Next caller, please state your name
and affiliation for the record. You have one minute. Your time
starts now.
Caller, ending
with the last four digits, 2629,
you are now live. Please start your
public comment.
Yes, this is John
from Napa and I'm a parent
of two school-age
children.
This whole process has been
extremely frustrating by
watching the politics
that have come to the surface here
in Napa. Meanwhile,
the school has been closing
the
good options that had existed for
kids in our community, including
our kids
and we have reached
the point of where we've pulled
one kid out and are paying money to
send her to private
school and are struggling
with what to do next. The options
that had existed would have been
a much better situation than are now
and
it seems the politics
and the lobbying efforts
behind the scenes have been pretty blatant to those
of us here in Napa.
Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. You have one minute. Your time
starts now.
I'm just calling in
support of
my promise. I'm really
disappointed with
what the last
caller said.
How political
this has all gotten
around the school.
So I'm just
calling to express my support.
Thank you very much.
Thank you. Next caller, please state
your name and affiliation for the record. You have one minute.
Your time starts now.
Caller, ending in the last
four digits.
Go ahead.
Yes. My name is
Jamoke Hinton. I'm with the California Charter
School Association
and I would hope that
again previous callers
we would note that
politics is not necessary when we're looking
at quality of education.
So we support
this
vote as it's going forward. Thank you.
Thank you.
That concludes public comment for
item number 12.
Thank you very much.
At this point, I'd
like to ask our liaisons,
Vice President Glover-Woods and
Member Olkens, if they'd like to make some
initial comments as we go into board
discussion.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
First of all, I'd like to thank
the petitioners and the
district and county representatives for their
presentation today and
mostly would like to thank
all of the callers who called in during public comment.
It's quite evident that
there are strong feelings and passions
on both sides of the item
that we have before us today.
I just
wanted to take a moment to
really bring
back to the forefront the two choices
that we have in front of us.
And based upon the
information that we have received
and this public hearing,
we as a board need to decide
one of two things.
We need to decide if we will
reverse the decision that
was made by Napa Valley Unified School District
and the Napa County Board of Education
because we feel that there
is evidence that there was an abuse of
discretion by the county
and the district
or
we can choose
that.
In other words, I should have announced
that we've closed the public hearing
at 12, 12 p.m.
Please continue.
Thank you, thank you.
So going back to the two
decisions that we have in front of us.
One would be to reverse the decision
that was made by the district and the
county board because we feel
that there is evidence in the documentary
record that there was an
abuse of discretion made
by the district and the county board.
Or we would uphold
the decision made by both of those
entities and that decision was
that they denied the charter petition.
The last piece I'd like to
add is that it's really
important and it's very
challenging, especially for those of us
who are practitioners and educators
in the field to
but we need to understand
that we have to make our determination
based on if there's
evidence in the documentary record
that supports the allegations
of abuse of discretion.
We cannot make our decision
based upon whether we agree
with the findings or disagree with the
findings or agree with the action
or disagree with the action.
And as I said, I believe that's
challenging at times for those of us
who are in the field and can
bring that lens as well.
But the decision before
us requires us to make a
decision based on if there was an
abuse of discretion and if that abuse
of discretion is supported by the
evidence that's in the documentary record.
So I'll reserve my additional
comments and questions for
our board discussion and I'd like
to invite
Member Olken to also provide
some initial comments before we go
into discussion.
Thank you, Vice
President of Black Clover Woods.
And I want to start by
just acknowledging
the incredible amount of work
and time and thought
that has gone into this process
thus far, from the petitioners
to the district,
to the county,
to the CDE,
to all the callers.
As Member Glover Woods
said, there's clearly strong
feelings on both sides
and there's also been a lot of
thought and
a lot of care about what
is best in the best interest
of students across the state.
So I just want to start with that and thank everybody who called in.
It's important
to hear all those perspectives and I really
they are
in my
they're here in my heart
on all sides. So thank you.
I'm just
going to offer a few
additional framing thoughts
before we start our board discussion.
So as you know, this is only
the second time that we are hearing
a charter school
appeal under
AB 1505 here
at the state board. And in fact
for the petitioners and governing
bodies along the way,
they're also working through this process
for the first time.
We heard that
I think
in both sets of
presentations. And again,
I appreciate these are hard.
This is a hard new process and we're all
working to do right by it.
So we have a new role.
Instead of providing a new
review of the merits of the proposed
charter, we are simply
reviewing the process by which those
merits were determined.
And as Member Glover
Wood said, that may be kind of
uncomfortable for us.
But it is the role
that we have been prescribed by
law. So some of the questions
that we need to be asking ourselves
are, was the
process fair
and lawful?
Was it free from bias?
And I would add
just like we must do in making all
decisions in our roles as educators,
we're students at the heart
of the decision making process.
On that note, one important
thing I'd like to emphasize
is that even in this new era
in which AB 1505
gives local governing bodies more
control over the charter
petition process and
more legal reasons to deny a petition,
I want to remind
us that as we consider this
item, the assumption in
law is still that charter
schools play an important role
in the public education landscape
and should be encouraged.
That's still the basis
that was not changed by 1505
and that's still at
the heart of
Ed code related to charter schools.
And I too will, I have
some further thoughts and questions, but
I'll save those for just a little bit
later as
our discussion proceeds.
Thank you.
I'm going to
also offer a couple
of thoughts about the framing for
our discussion and I just want to
note that board members obviously
should raise their zoom hands if they want to
make comments as we get into discussion
and remind
the panelists that if a board member has
a question for you, then you'll be
recognized and unmuted so that you can
respond, but please do not
raise your hand or
expect to be acknowledged during the board's
deliberation otherwise,
unless there's a direct question for
you.
I want to just offer a couple
more thoughts about the
complex framework
where we're working in here.
I want to note that I appreciate
hearing from members of the community
and it sounds as
though the district has developed a strong
communication to parents
and members of the community that the programs
they care about would be threatened
by the approval of the charter.
And I'm empathetic with their fearfulness
that that kind of messaging
can create. Every parent
is deeply and appropriately
concerned about the welfare of their
child.
Our job is to look at this
case in the context of
setting
some parameters for how we will
consider the immediate case and
cases in the future.
There are some procedural
questions about the timing of the appeal
petition being sent to the county and the
district and about the availability
of written findings at the time of
the vote. Some of those
questions are troubling.
The evidence before
us, as we've heard, can be
read either way.
There are also
questions about the proper
role of the county and the state
in reviewing district actions.
With respect to the
educational analysis, the county
statement of findings noted
they did not agree with the district's
analysis and the findings
that the petitioners were demonstrably
unlikely to successfully implement
the program.
In fact, they noted that
they thought that
the MCMS
were providing enrolled students with
educational benefit in a program
substantially similar to River
Middle School, a school that had been
operating for more than 20 years.
Within the district was
being closed this school year
and
offered a similar
program. They later
noted that
the
program that was offered
has been part of a
series of programs in the
New Tech Network founded in
Napa. These are
project-based schools.
So there is an elementary New
Tech school, a
New Tech high school,
and this would be providing a
middle school.
Apparently the
district had
closed River Middle School
charter school
on the condition that it would
continue to be operated by the district
using that model of instruction
and the transition was
effective for one year, 2019-20,
and then the
River Middle School was closed,
had a full enrollment
with a waitlist every year, consistently
strong academic performance.
So the county
sort of both
laid out for multiple paragraphs
what they thought were the virtues
of the petition and
their reasons for approving it educationally
and noted that
it was
potentially still showing a particular need
in that particular district
given the history of the district.
So the sole basis for the
county's denial was
a fiscal impact
statement and one of our questions for
us is what constitutes an
appropriate showing of
fiscal impact.
This is a different
basis than what
we were talking about
yesterday. The
fiscal impact basis
is under a different criterion of
the law, not the one about
receivership and fiscal distress,
but a criterion that requires a finding
that the charter school is demonstrably
unlikely to serve the interests of the
entire community in which the school
is proposing to locate. And you heard that
language in many of the comments.
Analysis
shall include consideration
of the fiscal impact of the proposed
charter school and detail specific
facts and circumstances that
analyze and consider
the following factors including the extent
to which the proposed charter would
substantially undermine existing services
academic offerings or program
offerings.
And this is
going to be a challenging
framework for
other districts as well as the
one that we're considering. Because
of course no single school
charter or otherwise
does serve all the
children in the community.
So a literal translation
of the interests of the entire
community could lead to the denial
of all charters. And of
course any charter school will have
an impact on the district
fiscal situation
and loss of ADA as district
students enroll in the new charter
school. So one question we have
is what should the standard be?
The analysis is based on the
fact of ongoing decline in enrollment
in the district, about which
there was data presented at the time
before meeting. And this goes to the
question of were there written findings
of fact? The decline
was suggested that it would likely
require reduction in staff being
accelerated by the loss of students
going to the charter school.
However, I would note that that would be
the case in any district or school with declining
enrollment that maintains a
constant ratio between the number of
students and staff. Depending on how
the shift is managed, it may
or may not undermine the services offered
to students, which is
by the status specific finding
and evidence that the new charter
must substantially undermine district
services and offerings.
That did not really occur
in that way at the
Sunday board meeting.
At the same time, the findings document
noted that there were other factors that could
change assumptions about the teacher budget.
On the one hand, there were
the questions about the enrollment of
the current students, some
of whose parents had stated they'd leave
the district. But on the
other hand, the projected increase in enrollment
due to TK students and estimated
416 new students
by 2025-26
would more than offset the potentially
300 and some students
who might ultimately attend
the middle school. And at a
time when the state has increased
allocations to education,
including in the LCFS
formula, funding for TK,
after school summer programs and meals,
there aren't many new
factors that are shaping budgeting
decisions for districts. So it's
clear that a mere finding of potential
fiscal impact of declining enrollment
is not enough
to establish that a proposed
charter school does not serve the interests of
the whole community. So I think
these are questions that we're going to need to
work our way through.
There's also the question that
even though the documentary records
from the county notes that the district
broke a promise to their parents and made
decisions that the county questioned,
including not locating
the school where there was room for
such a school and
another building.
The law specifies that the county's
review is independent and
de novo, and it is not a review
of the district's process of finding.
The county board
is instructed accordingly
that it should not take
underdetermined whether the district
findings were correct, whether petitioners
were treated fairly, and so on.
And a critical issue
then is that the county cannot make this
determination. Where does that determination
lie? And in fact,
it may lie with us.
So I think we
I want to open the discussion at this
point, but simply note
that there are different
framings on which one might
tackle this question
of whether it was an abuse of discretion
at either level of the
process.
And let's see who wants to launch
us into discussion.
We'll start with
member
Orozco Gonzalez.
Thank you again for such a
thorough presentation
and for all the public comments.
I think they were very informative
in understanding the whole
aspect in the entire picture.
I just have a question in regards
to maybe to the Napa County
Attorney
about the procedural aspect.
On page seven and eight of the item,
the education code section
47605K
allows a charter school
petition to appeal to the county within
30 days and requires
that appeal to be copied to the district
at the same time. My understanding
is that the Maya Commons charter did
not follow the requirements of the education
code initially
because they failed to copy the school district
which delayed the start of the
90 day timeline
for the county to make a decision.
Am I understanding that correctly?
I'm asking for clarity.
Yes, you are understanding
that correctly. The appeal
was submitted directly to the
county superintendent of schools
and the school district
was not copied on that appeal.
The county superintendent of schools
after conferring with me
told petitioners that they needed
to submit that to
the school district as well.
The school district was particularly
concerned here that some items
had changed within the petition
that would require remand
and so we did make them submit
the entire appeal packet
to the school district so that
the school district could review it and
ensure that items had not changed
and that there was no need for remand.
Okay, thank you.
Next we have a member
for the work.
Thank you.
I had a question
regarding the written
findings that were adopted
by the county board
and I believe
I'm going to
first address the question
to Stephanie Farland if she's still
on with us.
Okay.
I will start with
Director Farland.
So were the
written findings
that were adopted
or ratified on April 5
reflective
of
comments or statements
within the staff report
and or discussion that took place
at the board meeting
on March 15th?
Okay.
Thank you
member Leverwoods.
Yes, they
were.
So
there were
and I believe
the
county mentioned this as
well.
They had 26
sort of numbered findings within
their resolution
to deny that they ratified.
I would say
that
20 out of
21 of those
the first
few statements were introductory
but 20 out of the 20 remaining
21 statements were present
either in the staff report
the county staff report
or part of the board discussion
at the board meeting.
So the findings
that the county ratified
the 26 findings
were not
a surprise. They were actually
discussed at the board meeting
at the county or they were
in the staff report.
I'd also
like to say that that staff report
is just that it's the staff report
that was posted
15 days prior to the decision meeting.
It's required by law now.
That staff report is not required
to be adopted by the board just as our
staff reports aren't required to be adopted by you.
So
just to make that clarification
as well. But yes, the findings
were findings that were just
either discussed, came from the staff report
or also came
from the discussion
at the county board meeting.
I hope that answers your question.
Yes, it does. Thank you.
Thank you.
Apologies, President Dilan.
I believe you're on mute.
Thank you.
Member Yashimo Ototari.
And then member Escobedo.
Thank you.
And I also want to thank everyone for your presentations
today and all the public comments.
Thank you, Board President for your
very thorough summarization of all of the different issues.
I have a question because as we're charged
with determining whether there was abusive discretion,
I think the order of operations is important
and it can open the door to the perception of such,
whether or not it was actually an abusive discretion or not,
it could cause the perception of such.
So I think this is a question for either County Council
or possibly Director Farland.
My question is, could the County Office Board of Ed
change their March 15th vote to deny the appeal
if it was found later that there weren't sufficient findings
when they were bringing the findings forward
on April 5th for ratification?
Could there have been a change
to the initial decision on March 15th?
I'm gonna allow the County's attorney to answer that.
Thank you, Director Farland.
That question was never put to me by my client
and so I did not research that question.
If they had asked at that time
whether or not they could change their decision,
I would have looked into that,
but that was not requested by the County Board.
And I just want to ask if Mr. Schultz has anything else
to add because he was at that board meeting.
Yeah, I mean, the only thing I would add is that,
when the final decision came down,
there was a five to two vote.
There was a split on the board
and there were those that were in favor
of granting the charter,
but ultimately the majority of the board found
that the community impact was significant enough
that it met that criteria for denying the appeal.
And respectfully to President Darling-Hammond's comments,
all of these criteria require judgment.
And as you know, the district had findings
that our staff report did not agree with,
but we did have one particular finding
that we thought the County Board should consider
and that was community impact.
And you can argue about whether it was material enough
to deny or not,
but that was for the County Board to judge, I think,
and not for the State Board of Education
to supersede that judgment.
There's a slide in the documentary record.
I think it's page 1,422
of the County Board's documentary record.
It's a presentation from FICMAT and School Services
about the impact of declining enrollment
and you can't cut fast enough, deal with it,
unless you do things like close schools
and adding additional declining enrollment
to a district that's already declining rapidly
and that's based on Department of Finance numbers,
not on local projections, does have an impact.
It means you're gonna have to cut programs
beyond the staff you can cut just because you lose students
and that's what the County Board ultimately decided.
Thank you.
President Darling-Hammond, I apologize.
I believe mute's still on.
I'm sorry, I'm trying not to make noise in the meantime.
Okay, member Escobedo and then we'll call the words.
Let me just say to the question
about how we evaluate fiscal impact.
There really is a, we need the entire evidentiary record
to be having this conversation in front of us
because if there were a finding
that having declining enrollment in and of itself,
even when it might be offset by increases in enrollment
for other reasons, that that is enough to deny a charter
would have substantial ripple effects
across the decision-making process.
Member Escobedo and then we'll call the words.
Yes, in the same line of the fiscal impact,
there were just so many items under the district analysis
where there was a cash flow issue
that excluded lease and utility expenses,
which made the charter have a negative,
I believe cash balance.
And then I see that the charter written submission
did not contain specific citations.
I mean, I see that really throughout the chart
that was provided under the whole fiscal,
financial and operation plan.
And I'm just curious.
I don't know if it's the charters
not understanding the district's facts,
but I'm just curious to the process
between the county and charters, is there like,
and I do understand that the burden of proof
is on the charter, but is there any explanation
to the charters understanding that they have to provide
specific citations to the documentary record
from the district?
I'm just really curious how that whole process occurs.
Is that a question you want to direct
to the charter petitioners?
I guess to both from the charter as well as the district.
So if we can ask the petitioners to respond.
This is John Lennel.
I can respond to that.
This is a new process, Director Escobedo.
It's very cumbersome.
As you can see, there are thousands of pages of materials
that we have to look at and review.
But we have a very tight window to do it.
So we have to request it.
Then we have to wait to get it.
Now, the statement that we didn't provide citations
is false, patently false.
And you can just look at the record
and see at the end of our letter,
we have numerous end note citations to the record,
tons of them.
The confusion I think is the state created a form
earlier this year, CD created a form
that they wanted petitioners to use,
but it didn't make any sense to use that form in our context
because part of our problem is the absence
of citations to the record.
It's the absence of things that occurred,
at least for the county, for what the county did.
I think there's abundant citations
with regard to the district.
Our focus here is mostly on the county's failure
to proceed in a manner required by law.
It is not possible.
Look, I litigate for a living.
And when I do petitions for rights of mandate to courts,
I have months to peruse and go through the record
and cite to a record of this size.
It's crazy.
I realize this is what the law gives us.
We're stuck with it.
The district is stuck with it.
The county's stuck with it, and now you're stuck with it.
But it's very difficult to do.
So we cited to as much as we could
and only could cite to the big stuff
because it didn't make a lot of sense
for us to delve into the little stuff
if we weren't gonna prevail on the big stuff.
So that's why we have the end note citations
at the end of our summary,
which is what the statute requires,
to the documentary record.
Thank you.
Member Glover-Woods.
My question is also for the petitioners.
I don't know if it would be their attorney
or the petitioners who presented.
I just wanted to get clarification on the difference
in the documents, if there were differences
in regards to what was submitted to the county office
on, I believe it was December 21st,
and what was submitted to the district
after that, and then the documents
that were submitted on January 5th.
So I'm trying to discern if there were differences
in the actual documents,
and if so, what those differences are.
So I can respond to that.
I can respond to that.
So there was no difference to the petition.
The petition is the issue.
The statute requires that the petition,
that the actual charter petition
that's presented to the county on appeal
be presented at the same time to the district.
My comments did not do that.
We inadvertently did not attach the,
we didn't copy the district.
So we provided it on the 31st of December.
The petition that was submitted to the district
is exactly the same petition that they processed.
In fact, we pulled the petition from the district's website.
So we actually pulled the version of the petition
that they had posted on their website as the petition.
There is no difference in it.
The district still though claim
that they thought there was something different.
They thought that we added additional signatures
to the petition, which did not occur.
So for the benefit of doubt,
what we did was we copied the district
and the county on January 5th of the entire appeal packet
as a courtesy and to clear up the whole situation.
But the petition itself,
which is what's required by law
to be provided to the district was without doubt,
it's actually in their briefs,
was provided on December 31st.
There's no contest about that.
Okay, so just a quick follow up question.
Thank you so much for that clarification.
So the petition itself was given to both the county office
and the district, let's say by December 31st,
there was no change to the original petition
that went to the district
when they had their particular decision.
And then on January 5th,
additional supporting documentation
was submitted along with the petition.
Is that correct?
Not quite.
So what happened was on December 21st,
there's an enormous packet of materials
that was given to the county for our appeal.
That's the appeal packet.
So it's required by the statute.
So it's the petition itself,
which we pulled down from the district website
and our opposition to the district's action,
the district's findings to deny the charter,
the things that you need to have for a petition.
That was provided to the county on December 21st.
Later that week, remember this is the holiday period too.
Later that week, the district contacted the county
and said, we didn't get a copy of the petition.
The law requires that we get a copy of the petition.
The county told us that,
brought it to our attention correctly.
And we provided a copy of the petition
on December 31st to the district.
The statute requires that we provide it to the district
that we did on that date.
The district complained that they didn't have
all the appeal materials.
So what we did,
which is not required for us to provide them by the way.
So what we did on January 5th was,
we provided the district a copy of all
the petition materials that had been provided to the county.
When I say them, we provided the district
a copy of all the appeal materials
that had been provided to the county,
which is our letter,
a copy of the district's own findings
and in our appeal cover letter, essentially,
the substance of the appeal.
The statute only requires that we provide the petition.
We did that on the 31st of December,
but we provided even more on the 5th.
Thank you.
And that's because, by the way,
I'm sorry, I was just gonna say that,
that's because the district was complaining
about the process.
The district wanted the county to remand it back to them.
So they would hold onto it for another 30 days
and perhaps do nothing.
That was the intent.
That's what was going on procedurally at the time.
And if you dig into this voluminous record,
you'll see that in the correspondence.
Thank you.
Erika, did you want to make an additional comment
or will you finish?
I wanted to, and thank you.
Thank you so much to the representatives
for the petition.
I also wanted to, excuse me just a moment.
I also wanted to ask for just feedback
on that same topic from the county office as well.
Thank you.
So what was the physical petition itself
was the same submitted to the county and the district.
The issue is that the petitioners submitted a cover letter
as well as nine different exhibits.
Some of those exhibits contained new information
that had not been presented to the district originally.
So the district was requesting to see all the information
that was provided and requesting that we remand
the petition to them if there were material changes
that required remand under the statute.
So we needed that information to be provided
to the district so that they could review that.
And if you look in the documentary record,
in fact, there was an agreement to redact those portions
of the appeal packet that were disputed
and that were additional information
that were provided to the county board
that had not been provided to the district
so as to make it so that the entire appeal packet
was the same information that was provided
to Napa Valley Unified School District Board of Trustees
and the Napa County Board of Education.
So there was a lot of come back and forth here
in order to get that appeal packet to the point
where it was the same information
that had been presented to the district initially.
Thank you.
I just want to remind panelists that if we want to call,
if you're calling me, you can certainly respond
but otherwise not to interject.
Thanks.
Any other members of our school can follow.
I have another question.
I'm looking at the county's findings
and I see numerous examples of fiscal and community impact
of the proposed school cited.
So including cuts of staffing and programs,
additional school closures,
entering into fiscal distress,
cutting 34 teaching jobs and more.
I'd like to ask the county to talk more
about the fiscal and community impact
of this charter on Napa Unified School District
and its students.
Sure.
So I could just ask that those that be framed
in the context of the findings of that
that were made at the board meeting, that would be helpful.
Sure.
So as the findings reflect and as the staff report
and the staff presentation at the March 15th board meeting
reflect, Napa Valley Unified has been in steady
declining enrollment since about 2015.
It predates all of these disputes.
It's based on demographics, it's based on births,
it's based on household formation in the county.
Nothing about this decision is going to change that.
Again, Department of Finance is projecting
that Napa County is declining more rapidly
than almost any other county in the States
in the top five, both for the one year, five year,
10 year forecast.
That includes their projections
for adding transitional kindergarten
and that is in the analysis.
So that includes the projections for adding TK students.
They're still gonna decline and they're gonna decline steadily.
So what our analysis found was that in that circumstance,
adding the additional decline of initially
about 100 students and growing to over 300 students
over a number of years based upon the charter
petitions projections was going to require additional cuts
to the district's budget when they're already dealing
with declining enrollment of initially over a million dollars
and growing to well over $3 million
if the charter met its projected enrollment.
And again, if you lose 100 students
and let's say you have a staffing ratio of 25 to one,
you can cut for teachers, right?
And that's an impact, but it's an impact
that you can offset by reducing staffing.
But cutting the classroom staffing
only gets you about 35% of the cuts you need to make
for the revenue that is lost for those students.
So you have to go and you have to cut elsewhere
to deal with it and Governor Brown may disagree
about whether an additional two, $3 million a year
is material, but what we presented to the County Board
was you may consider this material
and we left it to their judgment, right?
We didn't make a staff recommendation.
But the reality is, I think those of you
who've been practitioners in school districts know
cutting an additional two, $3 million from your budget
every year is difficult and it's challenging.
And while right now districts appear flush in this state
and Napa Valley Unified has healthy reserves
like most districts do because of all the one-time money
that has come in, we know that declining enrollment
is going to continue.
We know that we're not gonna continue to see revenue growth
and the way we've seen it in the past year,
we look at what's happening at the stock market,
the state's dependence on capital gains.
So we projected that this is going to add on
to your fiscal distress.
And also, as a reminder, and this is also
in the documentary record, the County Office
is in the position of having fiscal oversight of districts.
That's a core role for a County Office of Education, right?
The AB 1200 fiscal oversight.
It is an accepted fact in terms of school business operations
that when you are steadily declining enrollment,
you have to do things like close small schools
because otherwise you cannot get ahead of it.
And those districts that in the state
that are consistently in fiscal distress
are the ones that have not been able
to deal with those issues.
And so one of the things that the County considered
is the fact that this charter petition
was directly in response to the closure
of a small school program and that if,
and there's a letter in the documentary record
that I had signed in 2019 telling the district
that they needed to do things like close small schools
so well before this decision was made.
If a district has to deal with a charter coming
and taking the students every time they close
a small school, that's going to make it very difficult
for a district administration
to make those difficult decisions, and they are painful.
And other schools were closed
besides the River School that is in dispute here.
But the fact is they made decisions they have to make.
You can disagree about whether they close the right school.
I know there's disputes about how it happened
and bad feelings there,
but from the standpoint of fiscal impact,
it's undeniable that adding the charter school
and the lost enrollment to an already declining enrollment
creates a very difficult situation
for a district administration.
I hope that answered your question.
Yes, thank you.
Other comments or discussion?
Member Olken.
Thank you.
I was struggling to get my little electric hand up.
So I just want to share after having reviewed
the documentary record in great detail,
I wanted to share my perspective on this
for our consideration, recognizing that,
as I've said before, this is a new role for us
and it's an important time in the landscape
of public education, but I feel compelled to share
sort of my take on where we are.
After reviewing the documentary record,
I do believe there is evidence of abuse of discretion.
My commis charter middle school has made a compelling case
that the district process was biased.
I'm not convinced that it was possible
for the charter school to receive a fair
and impartial hearing and decision
from the Napa Valley Unified School
District Governing Board.
The district process appears to have required much more
than the already arduous process laid out by law.
For example, a capacity interview
is not a requirement of law and yet it appears
to have been held against the petitioners
when it was requested and held against them.
It's unclear to me why the district limited petitioners
to have only one of their content experts
at the capacity interview.
It does seem to me like there was an element
of intimidation in this process.
I'm concerned about the testimony and public comment
found in the documentary record,
shared at the ACCS meeting and even today
that verged on attacking the petitioner's motives
and intent to serve the entire community.
The charter petition is very intentional
in describing how my iconist planned to operate
in a part of town that in and of itself
would draw a diverse school population
in terms of income, ethnicity and language.
In my mind, the stark difference
between how the county reviewed the charter
and how the district reviewed the charter
is another example.
The county did not find one single element
of the charter petition to be flawed or lacking.
In fact, the review was glowing.
By contrast, the district review was quite harsh
and raised a multitude of concerns.
And while it is not our job to decide who was right,
this difference points to a significant bias.
In my opinion, the district process as a whole
was a clear abuse of discretion.
One of the big things we've been talking about
is the timeline for the county decision.
And even if we presume that their denial
and written findings fell within
the legally prescribed timeline,
and I'm not gonna fall into that.
I'm not gonna make comment on that.
The process by which they derived
their written findings was suspect.
The petitioners did not receive a transcript
of the April 5th meeting.
This limited their ability to make citations
to the documentary record.
This feels like a big process error to me.
As the documentary record shows,
while the county board discussed the findings,
which were written based on the recollections
of a subset of their board members,
there's quite a bit of discussion
about whether they actually captured
that discussion or not.
The county board based their determination
on the specific criterion of the law
that suggests the charter school
is demonstrably unlikely to serve
the interests of the entire community
in which the school's proposing to locate.
The reasoning was not based upon
which students the charter would attract,
retain, and serve.
Instead, it was based on the district's assertion
the charter would cause financial harm.
The district's argument about the financial ramifications
of the new charter seemed threatening.
Napa Valley Unified projects
that have to reduce the number of teachers by 34
over the first five years of the charter
would have to close additional schools,
reduce programs and services to students,
and reduce expenditures on contracts
in order to mitigate the loss of funding
associated with the loss of students
to my economist charter.
The district suggests that the establishment
of a charter school that will grow over five years
from 180 to 336 students
may cause a result in elimination
of middle school sports programs
and elementary school music and physical education programs
and counselors and intervention teachers and electives
and further closures.
They also alleged that if the charter were approved,
they anticipated renegotiating and or ending contracts
with the Napa County Office of Education
for afterschool programs, summer programs, and CTE programs.
These assertions seem overstated
and intended to intimidate potential supporters
of my economists, particularly in this era
when there are increased state allocations
to public education.
I am disturbed by the threats
that Napa Valley Unified School District
specifically named canceling contracts
with the county office.
This appeared to be a tactic to dissuade the county
from approving the petition.
It is for these reasons that I do feel
that an abuse of discretion occurred
at the county and district levels.
I feel compelled to share all this with you
and thank you for your consideration.
Thank you.
Member Klobberwitz and then Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
I can speak after Member Orozco-Gonzalez
if that would be appropriate.
That would be fine, Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Thank you, Ms. Klobberwitz.
I just have another question
because I'm looking at this and I'm thinking,
this is a question for Stephanie Farland.
It is my understanding that our job is to consider
the documentary record only and the CTE staff report
is clear that the petitioner lacks specific citations
and details to support the MCM's allegations.
While I see numerous citations to support the district
and county's findings in the record,
I'd like Stephanie just to speak a little bit more
about the lack of citations in more detail.
Sure, you are correct.
There are numerous footnotes
and I think we gave the exact number earlier
in my presentation.
The problem with the citations
that they weren't specific citations
actually showing us evidence
of where the abuse of discretion took place.
In one of the slides, I gave an example of citations
going back to 28 page reports,
citations going back to a list of findings
without being specific about where those,
where the abuse of discretion took place.
And from the CDE's perspective,
it is on the burden of the charter
to show us exactly where that is,
we can't comb through it
and try to make up that on our own.
So we are expected,
our charters are expected to have,
give us, and it's in Ed code,
specific citations to the documentary record.
And we felt that those were not specific citations.
Thank you.
Cause I see based on the review
and the appeal of the documentary record,
I don't see that there's any evidence
of abuse of discretion
by either the district or the county board.
I feel like the CDE's analysis
gives us really our duty as a board to implement the law.
And this is clearly a decision
by both the local district and the county board,
I feel has followed the law.
So thank you so much for your information.
Member Glover-Wood and then member Olken,
is your hand up too?
All right, okay.
Member Glover-Wood.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
First, let me say before I asked my question,
I definitely appreciate the comments made by member Olken.
One of our goals as a public education system
is to be sure we have great schools for students.
And that's inclusive of what would be a traditional,
what would be considered a traditional public school
as well as charter schools.
And I think that's where charter schools play
a very, very important role
in the education of students in California.
Also, I want to say that procedures matter.
And it's very, very important that as again,
we are all getting acquainted
and knowing how to best address things
that come forward in the form of petitions
that procedures, timelines and whatnot
continue to be followed.
I do want to ask,
and then I have another comment to make.
I wanted to ask Director Farlin
about what is necessary
when we're looking at abuse of discretion.
If the board were to determine
that there was an abuse of discretion,
does that need to reflect that the abuse of discretion
happened at both the district and county levels,
or could abuse of discretion happen at one level
and not the other?
And I think that's my question.
Does it need to have occurred at both the district
and the county board or just one?
It is the CDE's understanding
that it needs to happen at both.
Okay, thank you, thank you very much.
And just my, I'm not sure if this will be my closing comment,
but a comment that I wanted to make as well
and it goes a little bit back to the initial comments
that I made at the beginning of our discussion of the item.
I do believe that the statute is very clear
that as a board, we have to base our decision
on the documentary record and the evidence
that is outlined in the documentary record
as it relates to the allegations for abuse of discretion.
We cannot, per my understanding
and what I have read,
base that decision on anything outside of that.
Again, whether we feel that the district
and county board's findings were the findings
they should have come up with
or that they shouldn't have come up
with any findings at all,
we are to look at the evidence that's been given to us
and then make our decision
on if there was an abuse of discretion
and if that abuse of discretion took place
per the definitions that we've received.
So I just want to underscore that
and acknowledge this is a difficult decision
and I won't give any other commentary
on my thoughts on either end of this,
but it's a difficult decision,
but I just ask us to adhere to, again,
the statute that we have been tied to
and make our decision based upon that.
I will add a comment
and then see if we can move towards a motion.
I'm aware that we're gonna start losing
a couple of our board members in the next half an hour.
When we have this,
experienced this kind of discussion and hearing,
it does feel like a he said, she said,
and we hear different things back and forth
from both sides.
Like our liaisons, I went back to
and read the record in great detail
and asked for additional documentation.
And I do share the concerns voiced by member Olken.
I also think that on the question of the timeline,
you could make an interpretation either way,
but the charter school did send the petition,
which was the requirement of the law by December 31st,
which then raises the question as to whether
other elements of the timing by themselves constituted
and abuse of discretion.
And again, that can be read both ways
and we've heard both versions of
whether it was just the petition
or it needed to have the attachments, et cetera.
I did look at the citations.
I think in many cases they were as specific
as one needed to have to see what the record was saying,
although I think the CDE would have preferred
and I understand why the actual statement
or sentence or paragraph to be stated in full
rather than simply referenced in an end note.
And I am still concerned about the way in which
the fiscal analysis of declining enrollment was,
in my view, in the record from the county meeting,
not sufficient to sustain all of the statements
that have been made about fiscal impacts on the community.
So I do think that this case is a close call
and I think the county due diligence,
this process was a well-intentioned one.
But I think that this is a case
where we need to weigh all of those features
and I'm gonna have to turn off my answering machine
very quickly here.
I apologize.
In order to get the internet,
I've had to move all around the house
and that leaves me in the process of a phone call
that can be made.
So I do think that this is a very close call
and I think that it's important for us to be clear
as people think about our future cases,
both about the need for an even more complete record
for us to be able to examine
because we don't wanna be in a he said, she said conversation
and that we need to be very clear
that we're working together here to be sure
that the process is fair and impartial and unbiased
from the beginning and then complete and thorough
and with respect to all of the technical details
through the end.
With that, I think that it is sufficiently concerning
that we could find abuse of discretion
on multiple grounds in this case,
but I also understand that the evidentiary records
could be more thorough in our deliberation.
I will leave it at that to say I'm open to a motion
and we wanna move the conversation further
if there are any further questions.
Member Glover Woods.
Again, kind of based on the evidence
that was given to us in the documentary record,
I move that we affirm the decision that was made
by the school district and county board
to deny the petition.
Do we have a second for that motion?
I'll second that.
Member Rodriguez, is there any further discussion?
All right, with that, Brooks King, you call the roll call vote.
President Darling-Hammond.
I will vote nay.
Member Escobedo.
I vote nay.
Vice President Glover Woods.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Nay.
Member Olken.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Yes.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
No.
Member Porter.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
The motion fails.
At this point, I think we need to be able to
document our own findings.
So I'm gonna ask our director what the next step would be.
Excuse me, President Darling-Hammond.
I think at this point, this motion tied 5-5,
according to my account.
Executive Director Allen confirms.
So you might want to entertain a different motion
to find that there was an abuse of discretion
with specific findings.
Is that what you're asking for?
Yes, I thought it was six to five.
Oh, yep.
So do we still need a affirmative motion, is that right?
We would need an affirmative motion.
Okay.
Member Olken.
I'd like to make that motion.
I move that the state would reverse the determinations
of the Napa Valley Unified School District Governing Board
and the Napa County Board of Education
to deny the Maya Commons Charter Middle School
based on the State Board of Education's determination
that an abuse of discretion occurred
at both the county and district levels.
We need a second for that motion.
We do need a second for that motion.
I'll second that.
Thank you, Member McClellan.
Now I think we have to take another roll call vote.
Is there any further discussion on that motion, I should ask?
I want to ask our council, Judy Saez,
if that motion is framed in the appropriate way.
I suggest we have some specific findings
that articulate why you all are determining
that there has been an abuse of discretion,
and I would also add that should the board find
you will need to consult with the petitioner
regarding delegation of oversight authority
to either the county or the district.
So there's two more steps, I believe.
That both have to happen today?
I mean, the first one obviously does,
but the second one also?
Yes, I would suggest,
because otherwise then you're gonna have to bring it back
to the November meeting, and I think it would be,
I assume the parties would like to get started proceeding
with opening the school and preparing to open the school.
Member Olken?
I'm wondering if,
and I don't know that I'm allowed to propose this,
that now that we have the motion on the floor,
can we take a break to draft our findings?
I'm looking at you, Judy,
so that we can include them in the motion as part,
or we can include them in the record before we vote.
Sure, you can take a break now,
and staff can try to work on some findings
that reflect your discussion.
I would caution all of you
to not talk among yourselves at this point,
because that would be a vaguely keen violation,
but if you'd like to take a half hour break,
we could at that point come back with findings,
and we can also consult with the petitioner
to determine oversight,
and that can be part of your motion.
All right, thank you.
I think we may have a question for members.
Yes, and again, just kind of a procedural question
on this, is the draft of findings
to amend the motion that has been put on the floor,
because we have a motion and a second,
we haven't called for a vote on that yet,
so I just want to be clear on the draft of findings
that is taking place,
is that to be included in the motion
for us to continue to complete the vote,
and then at that point, we would move forward,
is that what we're doing?
I would suggest that we have the vote
and the findings at the same time,
given that was an issue with the county
as per your discussion.
Again, Member Olken, if you have some language
that you'd like to add about why,
I mean, you've had, you've been,
why you think there's been an abusive discretion
in particular, I think now would be the time
to propose that, or we're happy to take a break
and look at it.
I know we'll be losing some members if we take a break,
I understand that.
I can, I mean, well, I'm not persuaded
that the county has satisfied the requirements of C7
and provided evidence in the documentary record
that the proposed charter schools
would substantially undermine existing services
and offerings.
That's probably not quite the finding
you're looking for though, right?
So that is the finding, right?
Yeah, I mean, I wanna make sure,
I mean, additionally, the district's process
was problematic in reviewing the findings.
I believe the district also abused its discretion
by failing to proceed in the manner required by law
because it did not provide a fair and impartial process.
Those are sort of my two key findings.
I'm happy to add those into the motion
if that feels sufficient.
That makes sense to me.
I think those are the two that I wrote down
as potential findings.
Okay.
So we get first to simply go ahead with the vote
if we could on those two grounds with those two findings.
That is that the district did not hold
a fair and impartial hearing process
and that the county did not satisfy
the level of evidence needed to demonstrate
in its findings that the charter schools
substantially undermine existing services,
offerings or programs under C7, 47605 C7.
With those amendments and clarification of findings,
I would suggest we...
Shall I remove that?
Would you prefer, shall I remove with that entire language?
Yes, why don't you read it one more time
so everyone is fully clear what they're voting on?
Okay.
Yeah.
I move that the state board reverse the determinations
of the Napa Valley Unified School District Governing Board
and the Napa County Board of Education
to deny Mayacomis Charter Middle School
based on our determination that an abuse of discretion
occurred at both the district and county levels.
At the county level,
the county has not satisfied the requirements of C7
and provided evidence in the documentary record
that the proposed charter school
would substantially undermine existing services,
offerings or programs.
And at the district,
the district abused its discretion by failing to proceed
in the manner required by law
because it did not provide a fair
and impartial hearing process.
All right, with that motion now clarified,
we still need a second for the motion.
I will second.
All right.
And then I think we need another roll call vote.
We have a question for the discussion.
Member Yoshimoto.
Before we vote, Board President,
I just wanted to confirm that as,
I'm gonna try to articulate this clearly,
but as the state board hears this appeal,
we were to affirm that abuse of discretion
did not occur at one or the other,
district, county or both, right?
But it could have been that one of the entities
had evidence of abuse of discretion and the other didn't,
and that still would have been okay.
Does that make sense?
It is our opinion that you'll need to find
an abuse of discretion at both the district
and the county level,
because otherwise since both of the determinations
at each level are de novo,
then if you determined that there was not
an abuse of discretion at one,
then the charter school did receive
a fair and impartial hearing on the record.
So I believe it is our interpretation
that an abuse of discretion has to be at both levels,
which is consistent with Member Olken's motion.
Thank you.
Then I'd just like to caution President Darling-Hammond
that after this vote,
then you'll need to call on the petitioner
and ask them about the delegation of oversight.
So we now have a motion and we have a second,
and I think we need to call the roll call vote.
President Darling-Hammond, it appears you may have a question
for additional discussion of the motion.
Oh, I'm sorry, Member Rodriguez.
Yes, I just have a question about that first motion
that was made, because it was seconded,
and I don't think we called it back
before a second motion was made
and seconded by somebody else, if I'm not mistaken.
So I'm not sure if we have to recall that first motion.
And then I think we need to call the roll call vote
and Member Olken, do you and Member McQuillan,
do you agree to withdraw the first motion?
I do.
Agreed.
Thank you.
Thank you, Member Rodriguez.
Brooks, can you call the roll call vote?
President Darling-Hammond.
Aye.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Clever-Woods.
No.
Member Lewis.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Olken.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
No.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Yes.
Member Porter.
Member Rodriguez.
No.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
The motion passes by a vote of six to five.
All right, I know this is very difficult
and I do want to just make a statement
about sort of future appeals
because this is going to continue to be
a challenging process and I appreciate
the work that was done at the district level
and the county level and all of the folks who called in.
We will continue to consider allegations
based on the entire administrative record
and to assist us in that work,
I would encourage petitioners, districts and counties
to ensure that appeals brought to the state board
provide the detail necessary for us to fully comprehend
and meaningfully understand what transpired
at the local level as reflected in the documentary record.
And in the spirit of continuous improvement,
I'd like to urge local authorizers
to ensure that petitions receive an unbiased
and impartial review so that the processes
are conducted fairly and consistent
with all legal requirements.
Today's appeal was submitted before the July board meeting.
That means the district, county and petitioner
do not have the benefit of a prior model
when submitting their documentation.
Moving forward, the July and September appeals
will provide an example drawn
and an opportunity to examine our processes.
The state board expects that petitioners, districts
and counties will know and act
within the requirements of law.
And my expectation is that the state board
will implement the law fairly and impartially,
examine our own processes and continue to learn.
And this is the same expectation we have, of course,
for petitioners, local authorizers and the department.
And I invite you to join us in this approach.
And at this moment, I would actually like to get some
guidance about the next steps that you're proposing, Judy.
I think at this point, the law requires
that you take action to delegate oversight
to either the district or the county.
They will become the chartering authority at that point.
The law requires that we consult,
that you consult with the petitioner.
I think you can ask the petitioner now,
they're still on the line, which entity
that they would like to be the chartering authority.
And if you'd like, that requires
that you talk to the petitioner.
As a courtesy, you can also talk to the district
and the county if you'd like,
but you need to talk to the petitioner by statute.
And then you'll have to take a vote on that.
All right, where is the petitioner?
Who wants to speak for the petitioner?
I can speak.
So the petitioner's preference would be
to have the County Office of Education
be the oversight agency.
And then we consult with the county?
Or is that a decision that stands on you?
Is that a decision that stands on you?
You certainly are welcome to talk to the district
and county if you would like.
Well, I think we will ask the county
if they will accept the obligation
to manage the charter, oversee the charter.
So I don't know, to be honest,
that I have the authority to speak
for the county superintendent of schools on this.
It's my understanding we don't have a choice,
but I would have to consult with the county superintendent
to say that definitively about what we want.
If I can just speak, I don't believe
it would be the county superintendent of schools decision.
I believe it would be the county board
of education's decision,
and they act as a board, not individually.
So I would defer to the school district
as to whether they prefer to authorize,
and if they do not prefer,
then the county board of education will take that on
as required by the state part of education.
If I may, the statute is clear what happens here.
The statute says what you do.
Excuse me, excuse me,
but you weren't to recognize Mr. Lemmo, I'm sorry.
I think we've been clear that the statute
requires consultation with petitioner,
which we've done, and as a courtesy,
we're talking to the district and the county,
but Ms. Nix is correct.
There really isn't a choice here,
but as a courtesy, we will talk to the other parties
here on the line.
Well, since there is no choice,
we're courteously telling you
that you will be overseeing the charter,
saying that was great politeness.
It is with great politeness,
but I say, I will tell my client that, thank you.
And you will need a motion on this.
Make sure you note that it's courteous and polite.
All right, I think that that is the end
of our business then, is that right?
You will need a motion.
You'll need a motion on this, please, and a vote.
Okay.
If I get a motion as to the designation
of the County Office of Education
as the oversight agency for the charter.
I move that the County Office of Education
is the oversight agency for the charter.
And the second?
I'll second.
Thank you.
We need a roll call vote.
President Darlin-Hammond.
Aye.
Member Escobedo.
Vice President Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Lewis.
Member McClellan.
Yes.
Member Olken.
Member Orozco-Gonzalez.
Yes.
Member Patillo-Brownson.
Member Porter.
Yes.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Yoshimoto-Towry.
Yes.
Motion carries.
Thank you very much.
And I just want to thank the entire board,
all of the petitioners and members of district
and county offices and callers
who have participated in this today.
We know this is a challenging process,
that it takes a lot of creativity
to figure out where we are supposed to be paying attention.
And we look forward to even more well-informed processes
in the future.
And I wish everybody a good rest of the day.
This meeting is now adjourned at 1.30 p.m.
Thank you.
Bye everyone.
Bye.